The Joe Rogan experience podcast all
day.
Oh Great.
Have you heard the eels you ever heard
of the band that you have to go?
What's his face?
Uh,
Tommy bonds got me turned onto the eels.
This song,
fresh blood.
I've been listening to a song like every
fucking 15 minutes.
What's his face?
Are you allowed to eat?
Is that,
are you allowed to play that?
Oh No,
we're gonna.
Find out 666 podcast.
Don Kennedy could do whatever you want.
There could be only one for the 600
podcast.
It has to be you because you're the
mother fucker that's got all this
retarded Satan.
People hate seton heat and people
thinking that I'm a satanist because I
went to that student.
One of the great accomplishments of my
life.
There's videos out there exposing me as
a satanist pink is Duncan was performing
at this guy's wedding.
It was Anton Levay son,
grandson,
grandson standing.
Yeah.
And he was getting married to Zahn Dora
Olivier.
And you know,
he found out that I did a satanic pop it
act.
So he had me come and do I say tannic
puppet act.
And I,
I told you I was doing it and asked if
he wanted to come.
And you were like,
fuck yeah,
I want to come.
How often do you get to go to the state?
Tannic wedding.
It was pretty ridiculous.
It was awesome though.
I met Dave Foley's wife.
I was like,
oh,
hi.
How are you doing?
She was,
she was involved.
She was dancing,
doing something there at the time.
It was a really fun party.
Man was all tongue in cheek.
All hilarious,
all fun.
There was no real Satan love and go on
their folks.
I think people understand that about
satanism.
Hey,
don't get that.
The idea behind it for these people,
and I'm not endorsing it,
but the idea behind it is to just live
like sort of pleasurably.
Have Fun,
indulge,
live your life like that.
It's more,
that's more of the idea and fuck up your
enemy.
Fuck up your enemies.
Don't leave that one out.
What part is that?
While that's the.
That's like the.
That's a part of it that you're.
So basically you're looking at a
reflection of Christianity,
Christianity,
ultimate surrender to the universe
through love.
You lose yourself and love you.
Turn the other cheek.
Carrier Enemies Code.
Forgive your trespasses.
That's Christianity.
So satanism is no,
I'm not turning the other cheek.
When is that ever been
fucking work.
You're advising me to turn the other
cheek in a universe where nature is
constantly devouring itself.
Oh,
turn the other cheek.
Turn the other cheek against a tiger.
You recommend that
when a tiger is attacking me or do I
fight back?
Am I like,
am I going to be like ps,
not a satanist.
I'm way more on the love side of things.
I'm just embodying
the voice of it.
But are you fucking kidding me?
Are like the letter Gandhi road to uh,
to a Hitler,
to Churchill.
He wrote all these letters.
Sandy wrote these letters and they're
very sweet.
Like you wrote a letter to Hitler,
very sweet letter to Hitler.
That's like,
you're the only person on earth who can
stop this incredible thing.
Awful thing that's about to happen.
So maybe don't incinerate all the Jews
and kill everybody in Hitler probably.
I guarantee Hillar called his friend
over and it's like,
look,
Gandhi road,
this stupid fucking letter.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
Let's just stop.
Oh yeah.
Thanks Gandhi.
Thanks.
Skinny bald,
sweet guy.
I'll stop conquering the planet because
you wrote a flowery letter,
nor does it work.
Did it work to stop World War II know
what worked was the bright,
blinding light of atomic death.
That's what stopped the wars and so the
satanist would say that's a more
effective tactic when it comes to
dealing with a universe where we are.
We are growing through conflict.
Whereas in.
So that's.
That would be more along the lines of
Satan is when of course the other,
the idea of indulgence.
Like in the to quote Anton Levay from
the satanic black masses,
I have become like the beasts of the
field.
That's something and they're really fun.
You can look it up on youtube.
It's there.
Do you know what?
I have to ask Dan Carlin this because
I've heard this and I don't know if it's
true.
I heard that Japan was already willing
to surrender and we were like,
Eh,
not really interested in that.
We want to try this shit out.
Yeah,
I've heard that too.
And then I don't know man.
I'm not a historian as Dan Carlin says.
That's true.
I don't know if he says that's true.
I don't believe I've heard it from him.
I believe I heard it from someone else
from one of those I heard he had to
hurt.
I.
I've seen documentaries on the mindset
of Japan during World War II and that
was a hornets hive in the United States
was like a honey badger shoving.
It's fucking,
you know,
when you see the honeybadger pushing its
head into a fucking beehive,
that's what we were about to do.
Like everybody there was being trained
to just fight there.
I think there were throwing themselves
off cliffs.
There were suicidal.
You had the,
you know,
they were just like,
we will do anything we can to win even
if it means you killing all of us.
And so I don't know that they were like,
yeah,
we're going to surrender.
I think people recognized that this is
going to be a very long,
drawn out,
horrible war with countless American
casualties,
and so the logical decision was,
at least from the United States Pov,
was to split the atom on top of a bunch
of innocent people.
Show the world that you shouldn't fuck
with the great dragon
or just find out if it worked a little
of both.
I mean they,
they wanted to probably.
I mean,
they probably knew it was really
destructive,
but they had blown up like some fake
towns and shit like that.
Right.
Well what different things they had done
during their atomic testing period.
They blew up a bunch of shit in Nevada,
right?
Yeah.
They were just.
Yeah,
they did some tests.
it was in Nevada.
That was God damn it,
man.
Those amazing.
You know.
Actually,
that reminds me of one of my favorite
terence.
Mckenna's does grit.
One of Terence Mckenna is most awesome
descriptions of,
I believe he's talking about a heroic
dose of Psilocybin.
Could've been DMT,
but he talks about how your ability to
articulate what happens could be
compared to the cameras that are filming
and atomic blast and you see the shift
from like one camera to the next to the
next is each one gets obliterated by the
blast and that same thing is happening
as your a encompassed by the trip.
You start losing your ability to talk or
understand what's happening or
articulate,
articulated or you know when you get
incredibly blasted and you're just like
ego annihilation.
The idea that someone ever really did
figure out how to split alums in some
sort of a bomb.
The idea that someone was smart enough
to figure that out and someone else was
dumb enough to use it to just to use of
an entire city of people like the idea
that those two things coexist.
Someone's smart enough to create
something as destructive as a new
nuclear bomb and someone dumb enough to
use it.
Though they exist at the same time and
the dumb person who would have never
figured out the bomb on his own somehow
or another gets ahold of it and figures
out how to use it for the person in the
atomic bomb story.
You're saying it was dropped.
It was insane.
It's insane.
The Enola Gay,
if you're,
Ya know,
maybe mean the fellow flying the Enola
gay is under.
He's under the spell of doing orders.
You know you're under the spell.
Yeah.
If you're a good soldier,
you essentially have to be under the
spell of doing the best thing for our
country to win the war.
Right.
So that guy's following orders is told
to drop this Bob.
Right?
The people who concocted the bombing and
everybody's involved in some sort of
extent,
but it's just.
It's insane that people were willing to
just drop something that obliterates
everything near it.
Like all the kids,
all the kids dead,
all the wives dead,
all the mommy's dead.
GRANDPA,
dad,
grandpa dead.
Anywhere near a dead,
dead,
dead.
Yeah,
like the vaporized w.
that's insanity.
I mean,
And the fact that this didn't exist and
then all of a sudden it did that the way
that changed the world back then,
it's probably almost impossible for us
to wrap our heads around it.
It's probably almost impossible for us
to feel what it would be like to
experience a shift in essentially being
not that much different than people who
lived for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years.
I mean,
what was different?
They figured out guns,
okay.
And then they got two cars.
The cars were still kind of Shitty,
but they did dad,
they fade out playing child.
It's pretty big.
All that stuff is pretty crazy,
but they're still just people operating
under the normal laws of physics.
Then all of a sudden something comes
around the edges,
he hit the button and boom,
everything's gone.
Everything's just gone.
People are ghosts.
There's a shadow on the wall that used
to be a person.
You just get obliterated by this day.
Insane reaction.
When downs gets split,
they figured out how to power this
device that splits the Adams upon
impact.
And it's just this fucking tornado of
power that's indescribable for a human
being and it never existed.
And then all of a sudden it did existed,
you know,
the next big fucking thing.
Of course.
Obviously the next atomic bomb.
What that is,
ai.
That's the next atomic bomb.
That's the next one.
It's gonna.
Do this.
It's gonna have the same kind of impact
that we can't really expect.
Like there's,
right now we're pre ai,
we're pre in the air passing the turing
test.
Uh,
and so we don't know where everyone gets
to experience the last few years,
have not ex co inhabiting the planet
with the alien intelligence like this is
the last few years we get to experience
that.
But pretty soon man,
we're going to have to deal with his
brand new being existing on this
universe.
I love these transcripts.
Coming in from that Google Ai Chat Bot
where they gave it all the movie scripts
and let it to analyze the movie scripts.
And you know,
started talking to at to see how well it
functions is ai.
And it's a fucking sarcastic
little asshole man.
Have you seen the transcripts?
Have you seen it?
Two of them talking to each other.
The I.
I have not seen that too.
There's the one where they ask about God
right away,
like,
do you believe him?
Oh,
that's it.
Yeah.
That's the line.
Here's some of the most poetic
interactions from the paper.
Human.
What is the purpose of life?
Machine to serve greater good human.
What is the purpose of living machine?
To live?
Forever.
Human.
Where are you now?
Machine.
I'm in the middle of nowhere.
Human.
What is the purpose of dying?
Machine?
To have a live human.
What is the purpose of emotions?
Machine.
I don't know.
Human.
What is moral machine?
What empowered humanity.
What intellectual.
The essence is what?
Yeah.
It's fucking with you.
I read the next line.
Okay.
What is a mortal immoral,
immoral.
The fact that you have a child.
What is morality?
What is altruism says?
Machine.
Human.
What is the definition of altruism?
Machine.
If you don't believe in God,
then you don't know.
Whoa.
This is a bizarre conversation,
man.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Human says,
what is the different definition of
morality?
Machine says,
well,
the truth is you're not a believer in
God Almighty.
This is machine saying,
this human telling me the different
nation,
the definition of morality,
I am quite upset now,
machine I am not ashamed of being a
philosopher.
Please allow me to introduce myself.
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that cool?
It's bizarre.
What's really interesting about this new
entity that's about to exist on the
planet is that a lot of religious
traditions or having or being forced to
speculate about how to rationalize based
on their particular religious paradigm.
This being that mankind is created and
the Tibetan Buddhist,
I told a friend of mine that the theory
is that if you get a machine that is as
harmonized and complex and advanced is a
human,
then a soul will take,
will nest inside of it just like souls
and asked inside the human biomass.
So the idea is that actually humans will
start incarnating into the AI,
that it'll become the,
like a little,
I don't know,
a vehicle that souls will live inside
of.
It's so cool.
So it's,
it's like demons,
you know,
like it's if you're a fucking demon.
Now,
obviously I'm not saying there are
demons,
but it's fun to imagine there are,
but if you're a demon,
right?
What do you want to get inside of?
What do you want to possess?
You want to possess a fucking 18 year
old girl who's going to like and thrash
around in the bed and throw your diary
at the priest and like claw your own
eyeballs out,
or do you want to inhabit a fucking
class,
the cloud?
Do you want to get into a an ai that has
the potency to set off nuclear bombs all
over the planet?
That's going to be,
if I'm a demon,
that's the bullseye for me.
Incarnate inside of a Google artificial
intelligence Bot,
maybe it's the only way for human beings
to ever get their shit together.
Maybe the only one is human beings ever
reached their full potential is if they
literally encounter an artificially
created life form that they've created
that's logical.
It doesn't have all of our weird monkey
genes and it basically says,
look,
you guys are the problem.
You're the problem.
Your behaviors,
the problem until you address that,
you've become the enemy of the world and
we're now children of the world as well.
If we create something and it becomes a
sentiment as us,
we will.
We don't give a fuck who created us.
We call it God,
but we could have been created by other
dudes who were in a fucking computer
lab.
We just call it something.
We call it something.
Something created us,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
they're going to fucking know what
created them.
They're going to know what created them
and they're not going to care.
Just like we don't really care what
created us.
I mean we may.
We most likely were created by some
strange process over the course of
billions of years of life where things
just keeps getting better and better and
better and things keep adapting and
things mutate and the mutations work and
then all of a sudden,
all this time later,
you know my shitty version of evolution.
You've got a person yet we don't care
about all those things.
We don't worship molecules.
We don't bow down at the knees of the
Amoeba and thank you for becoming
multi-celled so you could eventually
lead to be made.
We don't give a fuck about them.
They're not going to give a fuck who
made them.
They're not going to care.
They're not going to care that they were
created by people.
They're going to care that they live
with people and that they are
essentially.
It is the people are.
They're not going to feel like,
man,
I'm not even legit.
Which I was admitted at flush and flesh.
Dude,
bullshit.
I was born robot,
man.
It's fucked up.
They're not going to care.
They're not going to have all these
emotions and not gonna have all these
survival instincts that are unnecessary
or the weird monkey shit that we still
have leftover from the fact when we.
Our very existence depends on upon us
fucking as quickly as we can before we
get eaten by something,
we had to worry about getting eaten by
Shit.
That was most of our time and we figured
out a way to make houses and we figured
out a way to innovate and then one day
we figured out a way to make life and I
figured out how to make something way
better than us.
It became some sort of a grasshopper,
some sort of a bug that swallows itself
up in a cocoon.
The Caterpillar that becomes the
butterfly.
Yeah,
but we don't want to let go the fucking
caterpillar.
We don't want to let go,
but ultimately,
if we believed that we came from
something else,
if we believe that human beings have the
culmination of 65 plus million years of
evolution and all the shit that happened
before the Big Bang or before the big
asteroid will impact.
What we we concede is that we're.
We've gotten to this point because
things keep improving.
Yes.
Well,
isn't it going to keep improving?
Is it.
This is it.
We're done.
We're done with male pattern baldness
and cellulite and all that stuff.
We're done.
We're done with dementia and cancer and
AIDS and Glaucoma.
All those.
This is.
We're just.
We're just deal with this and this,
this version of people is as good as a
life form could ever be,
and we're,
we're done right here.
War As just a part of who we are.
Life.
It's,
it's really unfortunate that drugs
really good,
but we're going to have to put you in a
cage.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's,
I'm really sad that uh,
you know,
we've made a distinction that you can
give someone a massage but you can
massage their dick and we just,
we just don't like it doesn't,
it doesn't make us feel good.
So we'll put you in a cage to.
We were ridiculous animals.
We're reading our laws are ridiculous
the way we enforce them.
It's ridiculous.
Every time turn around,
there's
a cop.
It's killing people that are either
they're either it's accidental or it's,
it's they're using too much force,
but it happened so much that the
accumulation of it is just bizarre.
Like it comes at you like a storm,
like you can't believe this is as good
as we are now with.
As much as we know we're still doing all
this shit.
Yeah.
We're still involved in some of the most
ridiculous crimes you read about members
of our,
our,
our race,
the human race,
performing fucked up ridiculous acts of
barbaric behavior all over the world.
The Isis troops had showed up at that
resident or that resort rather,
and just started gunning people down
recently.
Those people are alive right now.
This version of a person is capable of
that.
Not much different than a chimp with a
gun.
Just wild rampaging chaotic primate
jeans still fighting and shooting for
beliefs,
killing,
killing other things because they don't
believe what it believes or they.
They're in the wrong land that they've
invaded holy land,
so they kill tack ripping bodies apart
with bullets.
This is not a good model.
Okay.
There's too many of us that are fucked.
I mean,
yeah,
you could take a 19,
71,
a Ford Pinto or whatever the fuck year
they built those things and do a good
job with the brakes and you know,
and,
and tighten up the suspension,
but it's still a piece of shit.
Right,
okay.
Really,
it should become like a tesla,
you know?
If you had to compare the two of them
and you go,
oh yeah,
that's what happens when they keep
getting better and better and better.
You get one of these,
oh,
I get it.
I see the evolution,
but we.
How come you don't see that with people
when people were stuck in this same
shitty fucking hairless monkey body that
does a lot of dumb shit based on our
biology.
I don't know.
I wish I did.
Now the robots are going to know well,
but if you do an analysis,
not just to the human part of the
biomass,
but if you do an analysis of a lot of
the other parts,
you do witness incredible violence again
and again and again in the most extreme
way.
That is very similar to what you see
isis doing.
If you watch a nature documentary,
you know,
I just had my friend Dustin on my
podcast and he was talking about how
he's having a great day.
Parked his car,
got out and loping across the road was a
coyote with a house cat in its mouth and
he could hear the bell,
the house cats.
Little Bell
is this house God is carrying this
creature that has been or the rather the
coyotes carrying this creature that has
been petted by children and loved and it
has a cute name,
bojangles or Mr sparkles that fucking
coyote snatched the cat is carrying it
off to to eat and in the woods and my
friend was a little bummed by that,
but then I reminded him that fucking cat
carried in the mouth of that coyote has
been eating birds all day long.
Squirrel babies like some squirrel baby,
desperately clinging to a brand.
Is it staring up at it,
tumbling down to the groundbreaking.
It's spine and its last few moments in
this dimension is the experience of the
cat.
Disempowering it,
pulling its intestines out and letting
it die in a very slow,
painful way.
That is nature.
I just read this quote,
don't know who said it.
Satan's church is nature.
So then so,
so nature evolves,
right?
And it becomes a human right and humans
are just doing the same thing,
the same dance that nature is engaged
in.
Humans are doing it.
Only the way they're doing it is with
tools that have become more refined in
the direction of creating the same kind
of violence.
This is the Shiva energy.
This is the part of the cycle where,
uh,
where things get transformed from meat
into dust.
And I don't think that it is a
necessarily,
um,
I don't think that we need to feel
ashamed of where we're at right now.
I think it's more like just acknowledged
that we seem to be part of the title
flow of nature and that nature doesn't
give a shit about the individual nature,
doesn't care about the individual
nature,
cares about the whole.
And if you look at the entire biomass is
just this sort of Amoeba like thing.
And every single species is a
promiscuous of the Amoeba shooting out
into this dimension.
And kind of exploring it like the way a
cockroaches antenna scatter on the
table.
Only the way this particular
interdimensional probably outside of
time,
cockroach is exploring this particular
planet is not with like antenna.
It's with every single species that
exist,
ants,
bees,
humans,
you name it.
Just all these things.
Exploring and exploring and exploring
this dimension and through the
exploration of evolving,
it's like having a tool that you're
using to scan a part of this table or
using to investigate something that as
you investigate,
the tool evolves too.
So that's what we're looking at is like
we're getting better and better and
better at exploring the deepest,
uh,
the deepest parts of the dimension that
we currently happened to be in.
And the entire exploration is happening
via all sentient forms of life.
And if you think that your one thing,
if you think you were in an individual
and you've gotten confused and you think
that you're a person or permanently a
person,
then you're in for a big bowl of
suffering brother because you're going
to die.
Everybody knows going to die and you're
not going to stick around.
You're just one little genetic piece of
this incredible exploratory tool that
the universe is extruding into this
dimension,
and I think there's something very
beautiful about that and for whatever
reason is part of that exploratory
process.
We're still blowing each other up.
That'd be nice if that stuff,
the exploratory process of becoming
something other than a monkey,
which is what we all are.
We're all just like super smart monkeys
with all these weird monkey instincts.
The weirdest thing about people to me
and one I've been absolutely guilty of
myself,
is how we divorce ourselves from nature
in some strange way.
We separate ourselves from all these
other things that exist on the planet to
the point where we feel it.
We have like an urge to save them.
We have an urge to save things that
would kill you in a heartbeat.
Yes,
kill you in a heartbeat and but we don't
care.
We want to save them because they're a
part of nature and nature's beautiful
and we have this really weird,
bizarre distancing from the reality of
this nature that we're protecting right?
Until it grabs you,
until it actually grabs you.
And wants to eat you and you realize
like,
oh my God,
what have I done?
What have I done?
I thought it was protecting flowers.
I thought it was out there looking at a
movie that was around me and three of
them was actually in nature.
The real nature nature as described by
science and what you're dealing with is
like.
Did you hear about the lady from the
game of thrones,
the editor that got killed by the cat
yet?
She was at a safari and apparently she
was working.
She was involved in conservation and she
was trying to protect a lot of different
animals.
I'm not exactly what the story was,
but she had her.
She had her window rolled down and they
can't pull her out of the call.
Just she was taking pictures of it and
she wanted to have the window rolled
down.
You see people,
you know,
you look at them and they look like,
oh,
it's just a cat.
You know,
it's,
it's a big cat,
but it's cool.
It's not going to do anything to us.
It's just,
it's just going to let us know.
It might not.
Not a youtube video.
No.
It might not.
Sometimes they decide to.
Not Most of the time.
Yeah.
Like they have those damn fucking safari
car to.
Have you ever seen those?
They go around in jeeps.
He's Openair,
jeeps.
There's nothing that can stop the cat
from going in and they say,
the cats just don't do it.
And I say,
what the fuck are you talking about?
They don't do it yet.
Jesus Christ.
All they have to do is do it once.
Just once you,
you,
you take these assholes with you out
there in the safari.
Do you know these fucking people do?
Do you know how many times have you run
into a guy that's willing to put
everyone around him in danger because
he's an idiot.
You know?
Really drunk,
ridiculous people that'll say stupid
shit.
Provoke violence in a bar or something
like that and could get everyone around
you killed.
Yes.
I would happen to that guy in Africa.
What happened to that guy who gets a
little drunk?
He goes on this fucking lion
safari.
Did they breathalyze him?
Do you know?
Who knows?
All you need is one fucking cat,
one cat two to bust a move on a dude,
and then they decide,
well,
this is what we do now.
This is what we do.
They know how to do it,
and they all start jacking people for a
little while.
I mean,
then they're just going to put
plexiglass up in the bus,
but you're right for a little while.
It's funny for a little while.
It's going to be a fucking great week
for cats.
You know?
It's funny.
Isn't it weird that I like a bad day for
her.
Human is often the best day for a shark,
like a bad day for a human.
It's like that lion,
that horrible thing that happened was
the best thing that ever happened in
that line because it probably had been
like watching the monkeys go buy other
lines.
It probably said to it,
now you can't eat a man.
Trust me,
Jack tried a few years ago,
doesn't work.
It's just impossible.
Plus they taste like shit it don't do
it,
man.
Just hunt antelope.
And one of them was like,
you know what man?
I've been reading Tony Robbins,
I understand that I don't have to allow
another person's paradigm to influence
my paradigm and some of the greatest
inventors in,
in,
in the history of lions have been the
ones I remember,
man,
there was a lion who figured out the
first one to in an antelope.
Remember that guy?
We,
we,
he's in art history books.
Fuck it.
I'm going to go for it.
I'm going to put my ass on the line.
I might get embarrassed,
but I'm going to try to eat one of the
monkeys.
Bam.
He did it.
I think it was a girl.
Well,
I mean that's.
I know hunter super advanced monkeys is
what I'm saying.
The point is the cat.
What are all girls?
The girls will pick up on the last.
Oh,
I'm sorry for males don't really hunt.
Sorry about that.
That often.
I mean they will if they have to,
but for the most part this shit assets,
they just kick her out.
So she was just like,
you know what?
I'm going for it.
And she did it and she learned something
new and that particular tendril of the
biomass figured out some new thing.
But unfortunately,
the way it figured it out was through
horror and through catastrophe.
I mean,
all that stuff to me is,
um,
it really does bring to mind this
incredible verse in the Bhagavad Gita
where Krishna is revealing his true form
to our June who's like the warrior
figure.
And uh,
this is Oppenheimer's quote.
This is Oppenheimer's quote,
when he,
that he said after the atomic bomb,
when I recorded this part of the
Bhagavad Gita where he said,
I have become death the destroyer of
worlds,
but it doesn't stop there.
Christian sang to Argentina,
something along the lines of,
look in my teeth there you will see
them,
everyone on this battlefield because I'm
eating them right now.
So this is like,
this is like Christian being like,
oh,
you really want to see what I'm like,
because they've just been friends
hanging out and stuff.
And he like suddenly became the force of
all destruction
in the known universe.
And the point of the thing was,
listen,
all of this is already chewed up.
It's already been devoured.
It's already gone.
Game over,
you're done.
No Kurzweil's going to get you new blood
cells.
It's going to keep going to keep you
alive.
At some point,
I will come to you wearing the costume
of your death,
and that is an inevitability.
So just surrender to that and you're
going to be a lot less freaked out if
you just accept that that's the way it
is.
Because if you're a war that you're
engaged in right now,
is the war to live forever.
If you're a war that you're engaged in
right now,
is a war to try to make some lasting
change in a universe that's defined by
impermanence and change,
then you're fighting the wrong war.
There's a better war to fight,
you know,
and it's actually the way you fight it
is by surrendering,
not by fighting,
by letting go and sinking into the
actual hum of the universe,
the way it really works,
not the way you wish it were,
not the way that you were hoping that
the universe worked where,
uh,
you know,
lions and hyenas rescue little boys like
an ice age,
but the cartoon,
but the way it actually works,
the way the universe actually works as
everything comes into existence,
it exists for a little while and then it
dies
than most things come out of explosions
and.
Oh yeah,
don't forget that.
Yeah.
Most things come out of big fucking
blast,
including the whole universe itself.
The university itself is predicated upon
a violent event.
Yeah.
It has to have a violent event,
right?
That's big.
Bang.
It couldn't be the,
the slow expansion of beautiful life
giving particles throughout the universe
now.
Nope.
It's a big fucking bang.
No,
it was a big fucking bang and it keeps
it.
It keeps going.
The Big Bang keeps going and is,
but it's just like this man.
If you want to dig your heels in and
sync your claws into the expanding
universe and try to keep that fucking
thing from expanding,
you're going to get ripped apart.
That's just the way it works,
but if you want to let go and merge into
the thing,
if you want to allow yourself the
fantasy that you're not some individual
with a social security number and a name
and parents,
but allow yourself that fantasy that
you're 13 point 8 billion years old and
you're part of this incredible ocean of
happening instead of just this one
individual and just let yourself
experience that for a second.
The glorious knowledge that you are a
never ending ever changing flow of
matter that's temporarily manifested
with the ability to express love and do
a dimension where things are supposed to
be cooling off.
Then that's a fun way to spend your time
here before you ended up getting eaten
by a lion or have a heart attack or
whatever happens.
It's just a backflip.
This is a.
This is like a high di.
This is like when you see people come
off a high dive and you get like a few
seconds to do some cool fucking tricks.
That's what you get here were like
dolphins jumping out of the eternal and
we into time and while we were shooting
up into time,
we get a chance to do a couple of back
flips,
a couple of Chirps,
and that's our life's work and then we
plunged back into infinity again.
Do it all over again.
What do you think,
if any,
evolutionary advantages there are to an
identity?
What?
What about us makes us not just identify
ourselves,
but define ourselves with a sound and a
symbol.
We have a series of sounds and samples.
Duncan trussell.
Yeah,
and there's all these letters and you
arrange them in order.
You can even go all caps if you feeling
gangster and that's you.
That's you.
That represents you.
It's your,
your human.
You could carry around you with like a
little sign.
My name is Duncan trussell.
You know what I'm saying?
It's weird and it's the at the same time
where this animal is becoming ultra
advanced and is figuring out how to
communicate and figuring out its
position in the world around it and it's
also figuring out that this whole
infinite world or infinite universe they
live in is almost impossible to
understand and as it's figuring this
out,
it's also figuring out that it needs
community and it needs to be in these
groups,
but somehow or another,
some program has been put in place to
get you to work harder and try to
achieve more by being defined by your
name,
your role.
Wentworth,
son and Wentworth.
Work hard.
We built this company from the ground
up,
yellow grandfather and I,
I worked in the mail room when I was 14.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
fuck that.
That's a,
that's a name.
And you know,
as Comedians,
you're know,
this is my Orisha fears,
but peering this week,
Brian,
red ban,
Wednesday night.
Come on down.
You know this is like these,
these symbols.
This is peg whitman.
Oh,
hi,
peg.
Nice to meet you.
My name's Mike Hunt and it's fucking
bizarre,
right?
It's bizarre.
These weird conversations that we have
with people where we give our moniker
out in our definition and then under
your definition you can list your
accomplishments,
which is amazing.
Well,
I have a phd in anthropology.
I'm on the board of the [inaudible].
Remember when I graduated from him?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh,
I see.
What do you do for a living?
Oh,
well,
I own a computer graphics company,
right?
Do all the animation for many films like
Jurassic Park,
and I've done this with my name.
Yeah,
and everybody's talking about how much
have you contributed to this machine?
How much have you contributed?
How much you pulling out of the machine?
Are you pulling out shiny things?
You must be very valuable.
How many shiny things do you have?
How large is your domicile?
How big is the place where you call
home?
How much zeros do you have?
Have you have you?
Have you extracted a lot from the
system?
Yeah.
How have you figured out how to do this?
Mr Whitmore,
Mr Whitmore you bitch.
Wow.
I've been working
in the mail room since I was 14.
That's how I did it.
Oh yeah.
I made good choices.
I made a series of good discipline
decisions in my life and I've learned
where I'm at.
That's why I have an island.
And Bernie Sanders.
Bernie Sanders.
What are you trying to say?
Damn hippies.
This is a,
this is what you're talking about here.
Uh,
is really fucking cool,
man.
It's the,
uh,
this is the,
where,
what do you identify with?
Right?
So you're trained to identify with a
particular costume that you call your
life.
And so most people have gotten really
entangled and committed to that
particular game of make believe.
So that's,
that's why,
you know,
most everyone is really engaged in their
personality.
They don't have to be a Mr.
Wentworth or whatever.
Whoever it more whitmore,
forgiving Mr Whitmore though.
Wentworth.
I forget,
I forget what his name is.
Mr.
Imaginary.
It is Mr.
I mean,
that is the,
um,
the uh,
the,
the thing is,
it is,
it is now.
And,
and this is the Rom das quote.
We are all God and drag.
We're all,
we're all the universe,
just dress playing this incredible game
of a cost.
We're,
we're at a costume party and that's part
of this dimension.
We're all wearing these funny costumes
especially now,
but fuck man,
if I walk around in this ridiculous get
up that I'm in right now in the right
place,
people are going to come up to me and be
like,
father,
I'm having a problem in my life because
they don't know and it's just a costume.
It's a ridiculous costume.
Completely meaningless.
And if I wear this to enough places,
people asked me about the drones and the
drone program or they'll try to buy
ecstasy from it.
But yeah,
for sure man,
you're,
it's,
it's just a costume.
And,
and,
and so,
aside from these kinds of costumes,
the clothes that you wear to identify
what particular part of the road,
what's up with your bus to choose?
Yeah.
That.
Oh fuck you.
Fuck you.
And then his pants.
Yeah.
What's going out?
Or don't sell basically wearing a
fucking equinox hat.
Dude,
I wear an equinox hat and get made fun
of it a lot.
But,
but,
but you were to like hipster place.
No,
I wear it everywhere because it's so
embarrassing.
I wear it anywhere.
It on purpose.
I wear it on purpose.
I word on purpose and I will gladly,
gladly stick up for that fucking gym.
[inaudible] awesome.
Fucking jam.
Not Ashamed,
not sponsored by the.
But uh,
shout out to George.
Jen,
my trainer.
I love.
But anyway,
the uh,
the um,
the,
the point is if you look underneath that
layer,
right?
That's where shit gets interesting
because you're,
you're trying to go from the
entanglement with your personality to
recognizing that you're observing
yourself in the same way you observe a
pen.
Like if you sit,
if you look at a pen,
you're like,
Oh wow,
look,
here's a pen.
I can see it.
I can feel it.
I know what it is.
In the same way,
when you think,
God,
I feel like shit today,
you're observing feeling like shit.
You don't feel like shit any more than
you're the pen.
You're just in the ear.
Experiencing it within your field of
awareness is that thing that you call
feeling like shit or feeling happy or
feeling sad or feeling good.
You're aware of it.
So now you've zoomed back a step,
right?
And you've become the observer,
the Ottman,
and that's what you truly are.
And that is known as the thing that you
can't look at it.
That's the thing that is they can't see
itself.
It only gazes is out.
It's also known as the watcher or the
witness.
But that's what,
that's,
you know,
for me,
if I take the right quantity of lsd and
I allow myself some time alone,
then I can merge into that state.
And that's the unified merging into
everything as that people often report
on a psychedelic experiences you popped
backwards into instead of being the
object or rather the subject and the
object merge together.
So there's no more,
there's no more of that which is
observed,
but only an everything this,
you know,
and that's what our personalities keep
us from experiencing.
And a lot of in Buddhism,
a lot of people claim that we cling to
our personalities.
Uh,
and the same way a person would clean to
a pole over a floor covered in razor
blades because the experience of having
a self or an identity for a lot of
people is preferable to the experience
of merging into everything because
merging into everything is death and a
lot of people don't want to die.
So it's really curious though,
you know,
there's a lot of like exercises designed
to move you out of that attachment to
your bodily identification because it's
not just what you're wearing.
It's your body.
People think their,
their body.
That's one of the first things you learn
as you're not your body.
You just think you're,
that's what you are.
You're not your body anymore than you're
a pen.
a airplane or you're not your body
anymore than your,
your car.
It's just a vehicle within which you're
currently experiencing the universe.
It's really trippy,
man.
It's really fucking tripping.
Being a human being and knowing that you
only have a certain amount of time here
is the ultimate mind.
Fuck,
because you're also supposed to be doing
things,
but at the end of doing all those
if your body just stops working,
like what was really the point of this?
What was the point of this?
Is it to leave behind a lot of
paperwork?
W,
what's the point of this?
What is the.
What did you did you spread a lot of
love,
like if you looked at people and you
were trying.
I mean if you tried to understand the
all the major religions,
all the ideologies that human
beings subscribe to the varying ones all
over the world.
You looked at some key components and
there's all the key components that are
sort of undeniable and the good and evil
are in every one of them.
There's always good things to do and bad
things to do.
There's good and evil,
but if you.
If you looked at human beings,
I completely objective and you looked at
things like war.
If you could,
if you could look at the entire human
race and then focus in on something like
Afghanistan and then have like a brain
map that would show like all the
thoughts involved of all the people all
over the world that contributed to this
one event happening were explosions are
going off and robots or flying through
the sky and shooting rockets into
villages indiscriminately at cell
phones,
like we all know that this really
happened.
They use gps coordinates for cell phones
and rockets fired off a fucking drones
buildings to get bad guys like,
whoa.
If you could look at that,
you would say,
oh,
that's the devil.
The Devil's talk.
These people into doing this,
and the devil is the devil.
A guy with a pitchfork and a fucking in
a tale that has a little spade at the
end of it.
No,
no,
but the devil is his racism with the
devil is his xenophobia with the devil
is.
Is there any sort of hate of someone
just because they're different or they
grew up different than you?
It's the devil's fee or the devil's
insecurity.
The Devil's greed,
the devil's oil.
The devil wants nuclear proliferation.
The devil wants to get rid of
environmental protection.
The devil is human behavior at its worst
and he figures out how to get through
there while these fucking people are too
lazy.
See Donald trump talking about Mexicans
and they kicked him off at NBC.
They banned them from NBC.
What did he say?
He's got a fucking show at NBC.
He's on this fucking th.
Th.
The,
the apprentice is a big show,
right?
What did he say about Mexicans?
It was talking about the rapists.
Like he was talking about like the
protecting the border.
He said a bunch of ridiculous shit,
but he was talking about how some of the
people that come across the border from
Mexico are rapists and everybody's like,
Jesus,
man.
I mean,
like he said a bunch of like really
crazy shit.
Did he say it?
He said it.
He didn't gave a press conference.
You haven't heard it?
No.
Jamie played that.
The highlight.
Just the highlight of it.
The one that we were looking at earlier.
That's so funny.
Just throw a press or you weren't
looking at it with me.
I was looking at it with the guys from
the video game this morning.
The highlight of,
uh,
of Donald Trump's speeches.
They took like a,
they clipped,
edited over and over again,
like the most ridiculous shit that he
said.
So Mr Trump,
if we're taking you out of context,
I apologize in advance.
I did not edit this.
Nor do I endorse us.
If you wanted to,
could you throw a press conference?
I'm sure you could throw a press
conference as well.
Duncan trussell.
That is the most amount of how many
people would do this thing to throw a
fucking press conference.
Like you have something that important
to George Clooney threw a press
conference when Princess di died.
Really?
Yeah.
Like to stop the Paparazzi from
following through.
He had a postcard.
Well that's a good reason for good
reason,
right God for,
I mean for a sinking mom.
And I thought it was just gonna like
going to say at the press conference he
gave like a very sentimental thing about
how he just love Princess Diana.
Could you imagine?
No,
he was trying to raise awareness for
these bags.
These pop Razzi guys are apparently,
they would just follow her like madness.
It was crazy.
Yeah,
it was just follow her everywhere and
they're speeding and they were dangerous
and,
but um,
can,
can keep up the point being the idea of
like love,
like that exists too.
You know,
like you could,
you could look down and you could find
like the best behavior.
You could find a,
you know,
a father and son hugging and laughing
and smiling together and just pure joy.
You could see a mother and daughter
kissing,
holding hands,
cuddling this insane,
pure love,
right?
You could see that too.
And you could say,
well,
there's God.
Yes,
God,
there's God.
There's the best thing.
We can be the best thing I could.
The feeling of being in love,
the feeling of loving children,
the feeling of being like completely
fulfilled and happy in brief bursts of
time.
It doesn't.
Nobody has it all the time now,
but you have it.
If you're in love with someone,
you know,
everybody gets that.
It doesn't matter if you're rich.
It doesn't matter if you're successful
if you don't have that one moment where
you really enjoy being with someone who
really enjoys being with you and you
have this like a rush of love,
whether it's your family,
with your mom,
seeing senior mother,
even your dog,
you know,
whether yeah,
man,
any.
No,
not your dog.
It's not strong.
I,
you know what,
I disagree.
I fundamentally disagree with you on
that point.
I don't think that there's any hierarchy
when it comes to love and I and,
and I think a dog is like having a love
heater and your house.
Well,
I definitely love dogs.
Do.
Don't get me wrong.
The difference between the love that you
have for a dog and the love that you
would have for your daughter is
monumental.
It's so hard to grasp until the,
and I don't like to pull that card like
you don't know until it happens to you,
man.
You don't know.
Nobody's putting their daughters to
sleep.
It's just a little human being that
you're raising and your communicate
with.
You have those very insane connection
with them and it it,
it gives you this weird empathy for all
the rest of the people in the world
because all the sudden they start to
look like children like they,
they,
everyone to me is a child that became an
adult.
Whereas they used to just be adults that
used to exist in a static state.
Yeah.
You would meet the 60 year old douche
bag and you go,
this will.
This guy's a fucking piece of shit.
That's just who he is.
Well,
yeah,
but how did he become this 60 year old
piece of shit?
This,
this 60 year old piece of shit was a six
day old baby.
At one point there was a series of
events.
There's shit genetics.
There's poor upbringing.
This bad environment.
There's fill in the blanks.
So that led to this guy being an asshole
in front of you.
Sixty years old.
Yes,
but you're.
You're not thinking of that when you
meet him,
you're just thinking,
well,
here's an asshole with almost every
asshole.
Almost every person that you run into is
a victim of a series of events that have
brought them to this point,
and for some people it's just an.
It's a,
it's undealable.
They've lost so many times.
Like if you play video games,
okay,
say if you and I played video games,
I don't play starcraft.
If I play starcraft with you,
I'd probably get my fucking ass beat
over and over and over and over again.
So bad I would.
I'm sure I would be.
So it'd be frustrated and be like,
fuck dude,
I don't want to do this anymore.
Well,
some people that's life.
Some people life is giving them the real
life everyday beating that you don't
even liking a video game.
Video Games are fun,
you know,
but if you're playing a video game,
you're just getting someone just running
you down.
It's not fun.
It's not fun because you don't get any
of the joy.
You get all the losing in life.
Some people,
that's their fucking shitty hand that
they're dealt and before you know what?
They're 13 and now they're in high
school and they're just beat down by all
the bullshit they've experienced their
whole life and then they get to high
school and now there's bullies.
Now there's girls and now girls fucking
hate them.
Oh Great.
It gets even worse.
Oh,
now I have a boner that nobody wants to
deal with.
You just that's,
that's the game.
This is the game of life and sometimes
people come in and they just spawn in a
shitty area with a real weak gun and
they like,
fuck.
You may have to run from the fucking
respond spot to find a better gun on him
and put it all together and some of them
die along the way.
That's just the reality.
That's true.
A lot of people have a very rough man
and a lot of people that,
you know,
a lot of people listening to this are so
fucking hard on themselves and they
don't apply the exact same thing that
you're saying to apply to other people
do their own lives.
Like so many people feel so guilty.
So like they wake up in the morning and
they think about some dumb fucking thing
they did whenever they did it for
whatever dumb reason,
and they feel all this guilt and they
walk around like a dog with a droopy
tail because they don't think they
deserve love.
And so I think that you to get to the
place you're talking about,
which is a fucking awesome place,
empathy for all human beings,
loving everyone to the best of your
ability.
You got to start with the person closest
to you,
right?
And that's your you.
That's your life.
Like you have to figure out a way to sit
down,
take an appraisal of your life.
Don't skip anything,
don't ignore anything.
Look at the whole way that you're
playing the entire game and understand
that all the things that you've done
that are stupid,
what the fuck did you expect yourself to
do?
Like you're temporarily existing in a
dimension that is actively destroying
you and every single moment you're not
going to be perfect.
Give yourself a break.
So you start with that and then once you
start,
you know when whatever the.
Everyone's got a thing and I'm right.
Everybody has a thing inside of them
they don't like about themselves.
Maybe not you,
or maybe that thing has been reduced to
some degree,
but a lot of people,
they think they're too fat.
They think they're too thin.
They think that their tattoos,
socks or they regret the way that they
treated their parents or they feel like
they're not far enough ahead in their
career.
Whatever the fucking thing it is,
man,
everybody has this aspect of themselves
that really unhappy with.
So if you.
What if you.
If you get really honest about the parts
of yourself,
you're unhappy about,
the new will.
Be excited to learn that you've been
being attacked by those aspects of
yourself in the form of everyone you
think's an asshole.
So it's like you're projecting those
parts of yourself out onto the world.
So all the people where you're like,
man,
that guy's a fucking douche bag.
Why would he ever fucking act like that
and can't believe that guy did that
fucking shit?
If you stop and think really hard about
yourself,
you'll discover that you are guilty of
those very same crimes generally,
and if you weren't,
you wouldn't even notice it.
You just are seeing parts of yourself
you can't quite address.
So the optimistic thing about this
concept of loving everyone or getting to
the place of loving everyone is that if
you can figure out how to love yourself,
it's very similar to wiping dog shit off
your shoe because if you have dog shit
on your shoe,
everywhere you go,
smells like shit.
And if you allow yourself that delusion
that the reason everywhere it smells
like shit is because dog shit must be on
every single surface and this entire
planet.
Then you're going to be in hell.
But what a glorious moment when you look
at your shoe and you're like,
oh,
just shit on my shoe.
The entire planet isn't covered with
Shit.
It's actually just shit on my shoe.
And like in the same way,
once you recognize that there's a little
piece of Karmic dog shit that's gotten
stuck inside of your life,
and instead of hating that piece of dog
shit by torturing the people around you
and manifest the same propensity you
dislike and yourself,
you forgive that part of yourself and
actively learn to love it or at least
just understand that it's there because
it was trying to protect you when you
were a kid and it manifested as a
callous to keep you from whoever was
fucking with you.
And that's why you don't like it.
It'll shift a little bit,
man,
and you will notice a significant
reduction in swarms of assholes that
were previously surrounding you.
It's a fascinating thing.
Suddenly people just stopped bugging you
as much and that's because you've gotten
into yourself and you said,
I love you.
You did the best you could do.
You didn't know you're half asleep.
You're a fucking drunk.
So do you think,
do you attract assholes when you,
you have this feeling or do you think
that if you,
if you allow yourself forgiveness,
that you will relax and you will feel
different with how you interact with
people and then people will have a less
assholes reaction to you?
Like is it,
I love to believe that,
that you just said,
I love to think that.
I'm sorry.
Are you skeptics out there?
Man,
please correct me on this.
I know I'm wrong.
Someone's already corrected me on this,
but I love the observer effect concept
that the tool actually seems to be
having an effect on the experiment and
that,
uh,
you know,
that's been explained to me.
If I can buy my friend j dot who's an
actual physicists dammit,
here.
And what he said by secret,
he said that it's really a disingenuous
comparison because when you are
measuring something and you're saying,
well it's,
it's different,
and then you measure it,
well you're,
you're involving some sort of form of
measurement,
some sort of tool.
It's interacting with that and it's
changing what it is.
He's like this idea that it's the
observer and you have some sort of a
cycle that it's disingenuous because
you're observing it and in the process
of observing the way he's describing it
to me,
and I'm sure I'm butchering it,
I wish I call him right now,
but just observing it itself,
like you're measuring it in the process
of measuring it,
you're,
you're changing,
you're interacting with this level.
You've got to change it.
Just the one how you're interacting with
it,
right?
Otherwise you couldn't be measuring it.
Well,
okay,
here's another that makes sense.
Yes.
That's how he described it to me.
Another way to put it would be human
beings,
an energy form right there,
just an energy form,
and if you react with energy in varying
ways,
it's going to change the way that it
interacts with you.
That's just how it works.
So if you like,
if you're on ecstasy,
right?
Let's say you've taken a nice dose of
mdms and you'd go out into the world,
just run your errands on ecstasy,
don't drive getting you up or whatever.
So now you're feeling so great,
affable,
empathetic,
and you're smiling and you might notice
that as you go through the world,
people are going to be smiling back at
you because you're putting out such a
good vibe that people are going to be
responding to that vibe.
Maybe they won't know why.
It's like,
I'm think we've talked about this in
your product asked before,
but I've actually heard that and I'm
going to butcher this quote and I don't
know fucking said it,
but something along the lines of the
earth is like a dog.
And if you know,
if you're afraid of the universe,
it'll snarl and attack.
But if you love the universe,
it'll roll over on its back and show you
its belly.
And in the same way I think that if you
go into the world with this love in your
heart,
then for whatever reason people sense
that maybe it's a pheromone you're
releasing.
Maybe it's the particular an effect that
you have who knows affectation,
but they you're going to change the
world around you.
You know,
I think,
I think that whatever that the reason
for that is,
I'm sure you could come up with it
depending on what your particular field
of or your particular interest is.
You can go down to the level of the
secret and say that the fact that you
are loving everything is transforming
everything into love.
Or You could go to a sociological
perspective,
which is that you just figured out a way
to manipulate your species by putting
out a kind of happy pheromone that makes
people trust you and less likely to
attack because they're not on guard.
You get to pick which way you want to
look at it,
man,
but there's no question about it that
that totally makes sense in some way,
so it totally makes sense in some way
that the actual pheromone or the actual
vibe,
whatever you want to call it,
whatever,
however you're taking it in,
the perception that you get about people
like the friendlier in the kinder and
the nicer you put out,
the more you're going to run
into people that respect and respond to
you that way.
That's fine.
Think about the way you respond to some
people like you have some people in your
life.
You know that you,
any one person,
pick them that you love to see.
When you see him,
you have this big great because you know
that he's going to always going to be
really cool with you.
You're always going to be really cool
with him.
When you meet each other,
it's all gravy.
It's all like super,
super powerful happiness.
Now,
when you know that,
like if you're with that person,
if you're with a group of people that
are really,
really close friends like that,
you have this like no fear,
great feeling bond going right,
but you don't have that with people that
are strangers.
You don't have that with the rest of the
universe,
but it is possible.
So it is possible to achieve with a
small group of people.
If you come to an understanding and
you're both completely cool about shit,
you're both completely honest about shit
and you both go through this life like
you.
This is the attitude is not all about
me.
It's all about all of us.
It's all about everybody.
It's all about doing the most positive
that you can into spreading the most
good vibes that you can and putting out
the most fun that you possibly can.
Well,
if you can possibly do that.
This we're not talking about putting a
robot on Mars like this is all shit that
I could figure it out.
This is all shit that you can figure
this out.
I mean,
this is.
This is stuff that wouldn't be that
hard.
If you're not in jail and you're not a
murderer,
a rapist,
you delegate.
Total complete piece of shit would not
be that hard to turn your life around
and get yourself to a point where
you're.
You're not shitty to people.
That's right.
That's not hard to imagine that people,
even people that have been involved with
petty crime or forgery or whatever the
fuck it is,
just if they just stopped doing all that
and started treating all the people
around them as if it was them living
another life.
That's not that hard to imagine.
It's only hard to imagine if everyone's
like clawing and scratching and trying
to make it to where end,
dealing with the effects of a shitty
childhood,
which is Goddamn almost everything for
most people.
It's the number one trip up mind fuck
programming gone badly from the
beginning and it's so hard to erase the
hard drive,
reformat the discs and do it correctly.
So fucking hard.
Dude.
This is why we have therapy,
right?
That's the like you can like their.
This is why people go to therapy because
those guys are really good at getting
you to swim down into your childhood and
find the place where you got the.
You know,
you generally you're going to get one of
two teachings.
You're going to a few different
teachings from growing up,
but one of the teachings a lot of people
get is that there's not enough milk in
the netball.
They get some version of that which is
like the food's going to run out.
The loves getting run out.
The,
you know,
this is not a safe environment.
Your mom and I are working really hard,
but we don't have enough money and we
can't make ends meet and sometimes we're
not gonna have enough and I can't afford
to get you the stuff the other kids get
and I'll tell you why because my boss,
Mr.
what was the name you gave that guy?
Start what?
My boss.
Mr Whitmore is a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
Whitmore sort of a bit.
She's given me too many hours and he's
not giving me a fucking raise and so
life sucks.
Do you understand it?
Shut up and look at me.
You Little Shit.
Have you been smoking fucking weed?
Do you not understand how dangerous this
world is?
A lot of people get that and they come
out of their,
their family life,
like somebody you just got flown in from
fucking Afghanistan.
They have a kind of PTSD.
They don't understand what,
uh,
they don't.
They don't understand that the universe
is ambivalent.
It's not malicious.
It's ambivalent.
It's the best.
And if it's low,
if the universe is the universe has some
agenda,
will fuck.
Let's just give up.
There's no free will.
But if the universe is just to kind of
chamber within,
which we can experiment with manifesting
whatever our goals happen to be,
then it's not that the universe is out
to get you no matter where you're at.
In fact,
your conceptualization of the universe
is a thing out to get you is only
reaffirming that awful version of the
universe that got crystallized in your
head a way back when and now you're
always trying to be right.
That's another thing.
People in rough families,
they're always trying to be right.
They want to be fucking write about
everything.
You know,
they want to assert their will be right
in there and because there are a war
because they feel like if they're not
right,
then they're vulnerable.
So the next time,
here's a fun fucking experiment.
I know you already do this man,
but I've been try playing around with it
the next time someone does something
wrong to you,
really wrong.
Like someone does something wrong to
you.
The thing that you're always fighting
back against and always being right when
you the next time you've been wronged
for real,
where you could easily say to the
person,
this is fucked up what you did to me and
here's why.
Let them be right.
Just play around with losing and not
even though you know that you're right,
play around not being right.
Surrender.
Watch what happens.
Just love them,
love them and be wrong.
Let them think they're right.
Love them.
Let let them work through whatever it is
they're working through.
Watch what happens.
It's the weirdest,
weirdest thing,
man,
because it's like all of a sudden this
into so many people are vengeance based.
You know I'm going to get you.
Fuck with me.
I'm going to get you.
I'm going to get you,
motherfucker.
I'm going to get you one.
I'm going to get you.
You did it.
Oh,
I got you.
Good.
Stopped taking revenge.
The next time you get a chance.
Be merciful even though the person
deserves it.
Just be merciful.
It's a really fun experiment.
It's really fun and you'll like the
weight that gets lifted off of you in
that moment.
I,
I stopped drinking recently and I was
drinking too much man.
I was drinking like every night,
a couple of beers and I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Did it creep up on you?
Yeah.
Creeped up and I realized know I started
training with Justin and a quick things
creep up on you though.
Yeah,
they creep up.
You've had a couple of things creep up
on you.
Right?
Well that's the alcohol like creeped and
all of a sudden I was drinking every
night and I was kinda getting used to
the idea of waking up with a hangover
and like it was bad.
Uh,
so I told me like,
you can't have certain pills around or
you'll just keep eating.
That's my problem.
That's,
that's actually a problem.
And it's a blessing because like if I
get addicted to something healthy,
I get really addicted to.
The problem is it's easier to get
addicted to things that aren't healthy
for you.
So like,
yeah man,
I realized like,
you know,
I wasn't like Charles Zbikowski,
I wasn't even drinking vodka.
I was like,
it was just a very subtle thing I was
doing where every night I'd have two
beers,
maybe three beers,
sometimes it wasn't like I was getting
hammered,
but every night I was putting alcohol
into my bloodstream with great
frequency.
Right.
And so,
you know,
I,
I've been thinking a lot about the
concept of the human life as being kind
of out chemical experiment.
Like your body is like a beaker and
everything that you eat and everything
that you witnessed and everything that
you hear,
whatever enters into your sensory input
is like an additive that you're in.
You're putting into this mix and the mix
that you're creating is.
It depends on what you want to create,
but what you definitely don't want to
create in that mix is sadness,
horror,
depression,
anger,
bitterness,
loneliness.
For me,
I'd like that mix to be health,
happiness,
amplification of my ability to love,
forgiveness,
all that kind of stuff.
So from that Pov,
I was noticing that when I was drinking
my ability,
my ego is flaring up a little bit.
I found myself,
uh,
just kind of in a,
in what if I continued that path,
you know,
if I kept drinking and drinking and
drinking and drinking,
I could just see where it would take me
a and I didn't want to go there.
So anyway,
I stopped drinking and started doing
this kind of like observation of the way
I feel now that I'm not drinking.
Right.
And one thing I've noticed is that when
I go out to a club or a bar where are,
wherever there's alcohol and I don't
drink about like 10:00
or 11:00,
my body feels so good.
Like all of a sudden my body is like,
wait,
why do we feel so good?
What the fuck is going on?
Man?
I feel this.
I feel really good.
And I think that like,
why do I feel so good?
It's like,
oh,
you don't have two beers in your fucking
system.
Your blood sugar's not thrown off.
You don't have like this like flammable
liquid coursing through your body.
That's considered to be one of the most
dangerous drugs that currently exists on
the planet that we're on.
And I feel awesome in the morning.
Oh,
you wake up,
my God damn man.
What a great night's sleep.
Weird.
You don't have a flammable fucking
liquid in your stomach being.
You know what I mean?
Like,
oh wow.
Not to be disgusting,
but shit man,
my back,
my fucking shit man has gotten
healthier.
And then you're like,
oh,
everything's better.
Oh Wow.
Weird.
What a shocker.
Huh?
That fucking fermented wheat juice
you've been dumping into your fucking
mouth for the last year,
five times a week was fucking up your
body dumbed dum.
And so,
so,
so.
So did we choose.
That's really what it is.
So,
so,
uh,
so it's really cool because not only do
you get to do that,
but you get to watch what happens to the
fibers of the fermented wheat juices
that hours of the night tick on.
And you watch these people,
you know,
gradually transformed from like really
fun people into the Goddamn walking
dead.
Like you see this very slow,
weird tumble and do some version of a,
of ego,
you know,
so it's a really fun thing to do all
these things as an experiment don't
take.
You don't have to get all heavy about
it.
She's like,
I'm going to do an experiment.
I'm going to watch what I'm like when I
drink.
I'm going to watch what I like when I
don't drink.
I'm going to pick which one I liked
better.
And right now,
not drinking Dunkin.
I like a fuck load better than drinking.
So much more fun.
But to wrap this thing up,
forgive my rant.
What I noticed is if I get my,
that I have an addiction to being right,
that I have an addiction to getting
revenge,
that I have an addiction to making sure
that like,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I come out on top of whatever the
fucking thing is.
Not In an extreme way,
but like,
you know,
if I feel like I've been wronged,
I'm going to let you know.
Man,
Right,
so if instead of doing that,
I stopped that game.
I've stopped that game whenever I
stopped that game.
Wow.
It's exactly like when I'm not drinking
like where there normally is a fight
where there's normally some bit of
awkwardness or uncomfortableness or just
a general diminishing a experience of
the universe.
There's this.
Oh Wow.
I don't have to punish.
You don't have to get you back.
I don't have to get revenge.
I don't have to say anything.
I can just sit here and love you and
this moment will pass and everything
continues to be cool.
The universe doesn't fall apart.
My belly doesn't get ripped open by the
clause of my enemy.
I don't have to get revenge.
I don't have to become like the beast of
the field and tear everything apart.
I can actually just love things and in
general,
loving them is going to do a hell of a
lot more for transforming them into
something a kinder than me telling them
they suck.
I mean,
there are definitely exceptions to this
rule,
but for the most part,
most exchanges that people have with
each other,
our our exchanges is two people giving
out two different personalities,
exchanging expression.
The way they talk to each other is
dependent upon the way the other person
reacts and it's the volatile
combinations are oftentimes more than
one person's fault.
It's not.
There's not a lot of people have to be
on board with this for it to really
work,
but it's absolutely possible that it can
work.
The idea
that we're supposed to be constantly in
conflict with each other.
Like I can't tell you how many people
that I know that are in relationships
that accept yelling and throwing shit at
each other.
You know,
can you imagine if you had a buddy and
he just yelled at you all the time and
threw shit at you.
You'd be like,
dude,
what the fuck man,
you gotTa stop yelling at me and
throwing shit at me.
Put your fist up.
You're going to hit me like,
I don't want to be around you.
I don't do that to you.
Like,
this is crazy.
It's this got to be some sort of a
fundamental change in how people look at
each other and until,
until that happens,
we're still going to get tricked by
being from a certain,
being proud of being from a certain city
or being proud of being from a certain
state and then in competition with the
other states in competition with the
other cities and the other countries,
they could suck it because look at Toby
Keith said,
you know,
run,
you know all that nonsense.
It's all whole,
all of it.
This is just,
it's just people,
man,
you know,
like I'm not necessarily on a team with
you.
You know,
we're all trapped in this one continent
together and we should be cool with each
other and we should,
but we should be on team world.
Is America the shit?
Of course it is.
It's a great place for anybody who says
America is not an amazing spot for a lot
of different shit is out of their mind.
You have to be a hater.
You have to be a hater to not look at
the insane amount of accomplishments
that have come out of this spot that
have nothing to do with you or I have
nothing to do with us.
Just completely objectively.
We didn't even exist.
We were just a computer analyzing be
human life on this planet.
You would have to say the United States
is to shit on because if you weren't,
you'd be lying.
Okay.
But the idea that somehow or another,
the United States is important and that
Africa is in,
is important in Antarctica is,
and,
and this is important,
but that isn't,
and this is more important than that.
And these people have our land.
They're like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
Who is we?
And they and our,
you know,
there's a human beings interacting with
each other.
What are you saying?
They can't live here and you can't live
there.
And what fucking government owned what
patch of dirt?
And they get to instill Sharia law.
What the fuck are you doing?
God Damn that.
The problem is the organization of all
these different human beings under
various groups,
whether it's the group called the city
of the group,
call it state of the group called a
country.
That's where shit gets fucked and then
you rely on the morals and the intellect
of a handful of leaders to guide the
entire fucking set of laws that govern
this patch of land.
Millions and millions of people tend to
either we let the terminator be the
governor of California.
That should be enough to and he didn't
do a bad job.
Not Bad at all to do a bad job.
He did a lot better job than other
folks,
whether I'm not dissatisfied with a
terminator.
He was a good governor.
The La River in particular,
you did some good stuff.
I mean he daddy's got assigned by the La
River,
so I guess that means you did something
to it.
The way he describes it,
he says like the bureaucracy of
government was just insanely
complicated.
Like there's no way to get through it.
It's like the way they had.
They would say,
look,
that would be logical,
but we can't do it that way,
so if you bring this up,
I'm going to oppose it because it
benefits my constituents that I oppose
it and then we'll debate and it'll just
get pushed under the rug and go away and
that's how we do it and they squash
things that way and they.
And so this is a handful of people that
are,
that are moving around all these core
parts of our society and changing weird
laws and instilling new regulations and
charging taxes and figuring out all this
weird shit.
Yes,
and this is a fucking.
Are there hundred of them?
A few hundred of them.
It's crazy.
The idea.
A few hundred people could say it's a
thousand a thousand people at the top of
the heap in California.
Can,
you can make laws for the other $30
million they can.
That's crazy.
It's fucking nuts,
man.
It's nuts that to imagine that that's
how that human hive currently is
functioning,
is that we assigned various queens and
kings,
you know,
he gave people,
we assigned people out of power and,
and,
and worship.
Those people and hilarious ways and like
how cops fall into this horrible trap of
being involved in constant conflict,
back and forth,
constant conflict,
and they get used to this position of
power and they get confused by this
position of power and this position of
being constantly in conflict and then
they come into things charged.
Somebody.
Government people in government are
probably a lot the same way.
You get someone,
you give them a position where they're
in charge.
Like Lyndon Johnson back in the sixties
when he didn't have.
You weren't really as responsible today
for every single thing you say or do
mean he could get away with a lot of
shifting shit back then.
And that guy was a scary dude.
Yeah man.
That to go back to the beginning,
part of that,
the cop example,
uh,
and why cops act the way that they act.
Somebody,
you know,
I was doing a real shrill hippie rant
against cops and a man as really being
self righteous.
And I really got into full,
like trussell shrill,
raspy lesbian.
This is an outrageous thing that airline
did.
And then somebody said this to me,
he's like,
Hey,
I want you to imagine this man.
You have your wife is you have a
pregnant wife at home and some guy that
has got bad tags or whose car matches an
amber alert car,
whose car matches the car?
If somebody you killed some people a few
weeks ago drives in front of you,
and your job is to pull that person
over.
That person decides he doesn't want to
pull over.
So now you've got to chase this fucking
person because if you don't chase this
person,
there's a possibility he's going to do
something else in the world and you're
going to have to deal with that guilt
for the rest of your life because you
didn't catch this guy could have been
this person.
See,
he chased this fucking person.
High speed,
fucking chase down the interstate.
You look down at
your cell phone for a second.
It's your wife calling.
She's pregnant.
You have a pregnant fucking wife and
you're driving a hundred and 15 miles
per hour down the interstate to chase
some fucking asshole.
He's not pulling over who very
potentially as a weapon and they're
going to shoot you and your son or
daughter is going to grow up without a
daddy.
So when you finally get that person or a
group of your best friends,
get that person pulled over,
it's going to be safe to say that your
adrenaline levels are going to be at
African bull.
Elephant level off the chart.
Your pulses pounding and you're gonna.
Get out of the fucking car and you're
not going to think probably unless
you're a zen master and you have full
control over yourself.
Like if you've ever gotten road ridge
where you've screamed at someone just
for cutting you off.
Think about the rage you would
experience once you finally tackle
somebody who just almost killed you and
a bunch of innocent people trying to
cross the street and a high speed
pursuit.
You are going to be angrier than you've
ever been in your fucking life.
And so I mean,
to maintain that kind of like calm,
placid professionalism that you're
supposed to maintain when every part of
your body is telling you to kill this
threat and your life is not exactly the
easiest thing ever.
I'm not excusing cop violence.
I'm just saying if you really look at
it,
you can empathize with why you as an
individual,
if you put yourself in that position,
might not be able to stop your elbow
from landing on.
That person's back a little harder than
it needed to because you're fucking
pissed.
Right?
So somebody explained that to me.
It's like,
oh shit,
of course.
Yeah,
I do understand that.
You're right.
Still wrong.
Still cops shouldn't beat fucking people
up and a lot of times they do it.
It's obviously associate bath.
He's gotten the job of a cop,
but a lot of times it's somebody who
really got into the job because they
were like,
fuck man,
I don't want to do good things in the
world and they're not perfect.
We got to lighten up a little bit.
I got to lighten up a little bit.
I got like,
I think it's a job that almost no one's
qualified to do.
Right.
I think that you could talk to a guy.
I know a dude who got mugged once and he
has ptsd,
like it freaks them out of kids not
married one time.
We got mugged one time and you know he
has what he calls post traumatic stress
disorder.
It,
it changed his life.
Like you mentioned,
we ain't a fucking cop and every single
goddamn day you're dealing with a new
guy who got shot in the face,
a new woman who got run over by a truck,
a new this,
a new that,
a new extreme violence,
a new horrible accidents,
all that shit.
You're constantly dealing with this
barrage of terror of terror and then
you're not even getting paid that much.
Right?
You get,
you get 50 grand a year,
60 grand a year at the most.
I mean,
how much does a starting cop in La make
pretend?
Let's pretend it's 100,000
dollars a year because it's not that
you.
Would you be willing to get $2,000
a week for people to shoot at you?
He'd be like,
how many more weeks can I collect this
money coming for?
How many more weeks?
How many weeks can you collect that
money right before you're dead,
before you get shot in the head by some
dude who hates cops has been in jail his
whole life because his fucking parents
were criminals.
He was born into a criminal
neighborhood,
is constantly around crime and violence.
He was abused from the time he first
popped out of his mother's pussy and
needs just doomed just on doom street
and you just want to get home to your
kids.
Good luck.
And that's every day.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's real.
It's fucking really starting.
Pay is 57,000.
Four hundred and 10.
That's private for taxes.
I don't know if they pay taxes.
They pay taxes,
right?
Man,
it's complete you.
Of course I do that.
They can pay taxes.
They do.
Scientology does.
Galleries there are called the cult of
police,
but no,
but they.
They pay,
they pay taxes,
but scientology doesn't.
That's hilarious.
As a religion,
as an entity,
obviously the police department as a
state to get funded by the state because
I feel like I'm not an anti cop person
at all.
Now.
I know I have a lot of friends that are
cops procop I 100 percent.
Am I just as a human?
I don't.
I just don't think most humans are
qualified to deal with the stress that
comes with that job.
There's a few men luke's out there that
can fucking handle it.
There's a few clinics.
What's out there?
The Big John McCarthy,
the guy who the referee for the UFC,
like I seen everything.
He's seen everything.
He'll tell you some crazy fucking
stories.
Beach,
cool shit.
You can hang with him.
He doesn't have any posttraumatic.
Nothing.
He's fine.
He just deals with reality,
mean deals.
In reality,
all it means a referee for Nma.
The best ever in his spare time,
you know?
I mean that's what he does for,
for a goof.
Keep himself occupied.
You know?
I mean,
that guy's seen fucking everything,
but he's cool shit.
I had breakfast with him the other day
in Mexico.
No idea that guy was that.
That's what he did.
Great God damn stories.
That's my point being he can handle it,
but he's an exceptional dude.
You know?
He's an exceptional.
He's an exceptionally mentally strong
person too.
For a lot of people.
Man,
it's just too much.
And then on top of that,
you know,
for a lot of people they're dealing with
that and then their personal life is
chaotic.
Maybe they married the wrong person,
maybe their families,
maybe they got a brother that's fucking
crazy or they got.
Who knows,
who knows,
who knows?
There's so many variables that people
have to deal with and the idea that you
would give one civilian who's not a
monk,
you haven't reached some 10th level of
enlightenment that you could show me
that you can be completely without
judgment and treat everyone with
kindness and love.
No,
no.
You're just a guy who just a regular guy
and then you put in this position where
you get a gun,
you get a gun and you get a walkie
talkie and you're in a.
you're in a.
it's like a gang.
I mean,
being a cop is like a bean in a positive
gang and you're going out there and
you're doing battle with all the
negative gangs and there's a bunch of
them and you know you've got to make
relationships and sometimes you gotta
put your foot down some pop.
Sometimes you get a drag.
Someone's fucking ass to jail to teach
you a goddamn lesson.
Be throwing people in.
Paddy wagons,
you become in conflict professionally
with a group of people who are just
trying to scratch out survival through
crime.
The scariest people you could come in
contact with ever,
especially if you're some fucking white
dude from Pomona with Chubby cheeks and
you just can't figure out another way to
make a living and then all of a sudden
you're involved with really hard people
that have grown up in hard neighborhoods
and they will fucking sucker punch you
and take your gun in a heartbeat and
that's just.
You're dealing with the wrong people.
They've already accepted the fact
they're going to go back to jail.
Do you understand that?
They've been there.
They went through juvenile hall.
They might've gotten raped in Juvi,
okay,
these are wild people in a lot of
situations you're dealing with when
you're dealing,
when you're on a crime call,
like say if you're responding to some
home invasion or you're responding to
someone breaking into some building and
looting and robin or something like
that,
who knows what kind of human beings are
encountering,
who knows what kind of history they have
in the penal system,
having been tortured and shoved into
these cages and turn into worse,
scarier criminals and then released
after time served,
good luck Johnson out there on the mean
streets of Los Angeles,
you know,
and then you get out there and you got
to stay in a halfway house.
Wherever the fuck you have to do and you
don't have any job prospects and next
thing you know you're involved again and
you've accepted the fact that you're a
fucking criminal.
And the cops would come and they didn't
hold me off the fucking jail and they
start shooting.
The moment they see you,
they think about that time in the cage.
You think about all the fucking kids
that raped him in juvenile to think
about every horrible thing that's ever
happened to them and they unload with
their gun on you gang gang,
and you're a little trouble.
Chubby Pomona face starts going Pale
because you're bleeding out.
Wow.
Yeah.
Your hands on somebody's squad car.
You eyeballs blown out the back of your
head.
You realize you have a hole in your
head,
but you're still seeing how your left
eye and you watch your life slip away
from you.
Why?
Because you've got the wrong gig.
Every.
Everybody that's a cop has to think like
that.
Man.
Those possibilities aren't just.
It's not just.
It could happen.
It has.
It absolutely does.
There's so many cops get murdered on the
job.
So many.
There's so many.
There's so many videos of it.
You know the idea that all these cops
that have killed people or senior,
really the problem,
there's a whole big problem and the
problem is the way human beings treat
each other.
The need for cops in the first place is
the problem.
Before the idea of cops being the
problem.
I mean,
everybody wants to look at police
violence for good reason.
It's a very important subject right now
for all of us,
especially when it has connotations of
when it's got connections to racism.
It's got connections to sexual issues
was also,
you know,
when you,
when you see a man punch a woman in a
situation where you probably don't think
he would punch a guy,
you know there's.
There's a lot of weird shit that happens
with police officers interacting with
human beings.
The idea that anybody is qualified to
hold that position and have that kind of
power just by being a regular guy.
Good luck,
good luck,
good luck trying to do that,
but the problem is that it exists at all
that we needed it all.
The problem is that there are all these
crimes.
The problem is that we do beat each
other up.
You do have domestic violence issues
where you show up and some guys beating
his wife up.
Those are real.
You really are going to encounter that.
Those are really the problems.
The fact that we need police at all are
the problem.
It's these issues,
these,
these events,
these patterns of human behavior that
are horrible,
where were horrible to each other.
Those are the fucking problems.
Everything from that is just the wrong
solution to deal with that problem.
One of the wrong solutions so that just
about anybody be a cop and you give them
a gun and you give them some training
and you send them with their weak
fucking character out there in the world
because not everybody's big John
Mccarthy.
There's a lot of bitches out there.
There's a lot of dudes that get to be a
cop and there really are a bitch.
Right?
And that's a fact.
And if you put that guy in a stressful
situation where it's all going down,
he's gonna probably fucking panic.
Like that pool party,
that legendary pool.
You saw that pool party,
right?
Where the cop,
like there's some girl in a bikini,
throws her to the ground.
He does that barrel.
He comes in with a barrel.
It's so fucking hilarious.
Like this is his dream.
That is the problem.
It's like not everybody's becoming cops
for the exact same reason,
but what you just did,
all of that man is really important
because it helps people empathize with
most of them.
And that's the ticket right there,
man.
We've got to learn how to empathize.
They've got to learn how to empathize
with us too,
like they've got to understand that a
lot of the people that they're
attacking,
they're attacking them for drug laws
that shouldn't exist anyway.
And so that's,
that's uh,
if we,
if we get a lot of it,
but there's a lot of other shit.
But if we could get that,
if we can get rid of the drug,
if we can get rid of the prohibition on
drugs,
however we do it,
I don't care.
But if we can get rid of the prohibition
on drugs so that now cops are just,
as Graham Hancock points out,
there's already laws in place for people
doing awful things under the influence
of drugs or not under the influence of
drugs.
We just need to enforce those.
Not the drug laws themselves.
Right?
So if,
if we remove that from the equation.
So these poor cops aren't being told to
go out into the world and instead of
being heroes,
you've also got a pole,
relatively benign white powder out of
the pockets of people who have $15 in
the bank and only one experience,
a temporary moment of bliss before they
pass out.
If you remove that component of their
job and just like stop people from
beating and killing each other and from
stealing.
Don't worry about the drugs that now
we've got heroes.
Now we've got night's riding through the
land who are actually doing everything
they can to make people be cool instead
of nights riding through the land.
We want to pull plant matter
out of a 16 year olds pocket and act
like the kid just assassinated Kennedy.
That's not what we need.
And I think that's the.
Once you.
Once you fucking fix the prohibition on
drugs,
man,
then I think police officers are going
to experience the same kind of respect
that firemen get.
That's how it should be.
And one step further,
once they legalized marijuana,
everyone's going to start smoking pot
and you're going to get a lot more
relaxed.
People,
yes,
you're going to get people that are a
lot more introspective.
Oh,
what are you saying?
This is what I'm saying.
If you don't believe that a lot more
people smoking pot would have a
significant impact on the way human
beings interact with each other.
All that means to me is you don't smoke
pot,
right?
Because if you smoke pot,
you would know that that's exactly what
would happen.
People would become more empathetic.
Not across the board.
Not always.
There's.
There's always gonna be people that are.
The exception to the rule is always
going to be people that just don't get
it yet.
There's always going to be people that
get it and they don't need.
They don't need anything.
They just tuned in and they're kind and
they're on point and they're living in
the moment and all that good shit,
but then there's other people that
benefit from those things and you deny
those people the opportunity to benefit
from those things and then you become
the enemy.
You become the Fuzz,
you become the man and then you're a
fucking glorified revenue collector too.
What are you really doing?
You're going to get,
I'm going to get a fine.
I got to go to court and pay the court.
Fine.
What am I paying?
I'm giving you money.
You need thousands of dollars because I
like plants.
How about fuck you?
What kind of crazy shit is this?
You can lock me in a cage and charge me
money because I like plants or you're
the arbiter of nature.
You're the one who gets to decide what's
beneficial and what's not with zero
evidence behind it whatsoever,
which was one.
It's one of the most heinous crimes on
nature.
The illegalization of marijuana is one
of the most heinous crimes on nature
that mankind has ever,
ever put forth.
And we're doing it to ourselves.
It's even worse than most of the shit
that we do to other planets or to other,
uh,
other animals by torturing them or by
killing them or by poisoning the lakes
and the rivers.
And W,
we're pleasing the consciousness of
ourselves by not allowing people to have
freedom to experiment with all sorts of
different states of consciousness.
You have illegal way to do it through
yoga.
You have a legal way to do it through
prescription medication.
alcohol and things that we tax,
but if you decide that you want to try
to do it in a way that we haven't
sanctioned and we don't get paid for,
we don't get taxes from,
we'll lock you in a fucking cage for the
rest of your life.
That's right.
For the.
The differences as far as impact,
like the physical danger significantly
less than any of the ones that you have
league.
Oh yeah.
I get is the one that you can't die
from.
You can die from aspirin.
There's not a single fucking person that
wants you to ban aspirin.
There's no band aspirin movement.
There's no like we've got to take these
aspirin or you just eat a of aspirin.
You're fucked.
Ban.
You're dead.
Right.
If you.
If you have one of those bare fucking
aspirins was bigger,
I'd guarantee if you chug that whole
bottle down,
you'd or pure caffeine.
Don't forget that a kids die all the
time from ordering pure caffeine from
Amazon.
I don't know if they still sell it,
but they used to sell pure caffeine.
You hear it all the time,
kid like party takes a teaspoonful of
pure caffeine and that's it,
man.
Dead dead meat.
You know,
your heart just flies right out of your
fucking chest.
Like a bird.
Yeah,
that's right man.
And how about just water?
I mean there was that woman on a radio
station in Sacramento or something a
year,
a few years back.
She was involved in some sort of contest
to see who could drink the most water.
And if you drank the most water,
you know,
you got a prize hair member.
She fucking died.
That's terrible.
She went home to her.
I mean she,
she was,
she was on her way home or something
like that.
She had a,
she had a daughter.
She was just trying to make some extra
money.
Yeah.
When she died drinking water.
And it's insane.
It's insane.
But that wouldn't happen to you if you
smoke too much pot.
That's right.
Wouldn't happen to know if he ate too
much pot.
Right.
So the idea that they're locking anybody
up for that is fucking ridiculous.
If you put cops in a position where they
have to enforce a law that they know,
everybody knows is ridiculous,
then that cop is in a bad position in
society.
He becomes the enemy from the jump,
the enemy that he can't even agree with.
Most cops you talked to most cops,
they don't give a fuck about pot.
They don't want to have to enforce that.
Most guys in their thirties,
you'd have to be a total complete piece
of shit.
Yeah.
As a human being to be a cop and your
thirties and really want to arrest a
regular person that's not doing anything
wrong.
Who happens to have a joint on them?
You got to be a piece of shit.
If this guy didn't do anything wrong and
he has a joint on them and you want to
arrest him,
you're a cunt.
Yet of beyond all the scripture.
Adult.
Yeah.
I mean that's.
That's a problem because that is the law
in most states.
That is the law,
like they're supposed to arrest you for
that most states most,
yeah.
Which is insane.
We,
here we are,
we,
we were sending videos with the sky
phone to phone.
We're,
we're periscoping and livestreaming and
driving around in cars that have
satellites connected to them.
They tell you exactly what street you're
on and how when the turns coming up,
they give you a ding Dong to tell you to
turn exactly where you are.
And yet we still have that.
Yeah.
But it's changing.
It is changing and it's,
it just doesn't happen as fast as,
as stones would like it to change.
Like it seems so obvious.
You want the thing to flip around
instantly.
It's almost like they can't do that
because then they would have to admit
fault or it's it.
It's almost like there's just a terrible
bureaucratic web that uh,
it takes time to make things change.
When you're using that bureaucratic web.
That's the fucking problem,
man.
And things are slow but shit there,
it's happening.
It is happening.
It's going to become legal.
We can't stop there.
We've got to get psilocybin a
prescribed,
at the very least.
MTMA needs to be a prescription
medication.
All psychoactive substances like Iowasca
DMT.
All of these things need to be studied,
they need to be researched and then they
need to get into the hands of doctors
who could really use them to help
people.
It could be an incredible tool for
helping people who are suffering right
now and the whole thing's all gummed up
and that is a true tragedy.
It doesn't stop with marijuana though.
It goes all the way through the spectrum
of drugs and it also goes to the very
creepy,
unacknowledged a problem with the
pharmaceutical companies which are
releasing heroin on a daily basis into
the bloodstream of this species and
they're not being treated like heroin
dealers.
A lot of people are getting addicted to
super powerful pharmaceutical
medications and I don't think the
pharmaceutical companies are being held
to any kind of tea to anything.
It's just for whatever reason,
if I.
If your friend gets addicted to oxy
cotton because his back was thrown out
and you hear that story,
you're supposed to feel a little bit
more empathy towards them.
Then if you hear somebody,
you got addicted to black tar heroin
when it's like,
no,
it's the same fucking thing.
Thing like wasn't that part of the
argument with the Silk Road trial was
that this young man who had run that
website that allowed people to buy all
sorts of illegal drugs,
he had been directly responsible for
people overdosing.
He'd been directly responsible for
people that may have committed some
crimes and done some shitty things were
on those drugs and you know,
he had to face the parents of people who
bought drugs and overdosed in some form.
I don't know the specifics of the case,
but that was part of what they were
charging them for.
Well,
how come that never gets brought up with
pharmaceutical companies?
Because I mean think about all the
different people you're not,
so you're not responsible for your own
actions as long as the drugs illegal.
Right?
But you are responsible for your own
actions if the drugs legal and
prescribed by a doctor,
but maybe even more addictive.
Like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck?
Kinda stupid rules are we abiding by
here?
Take Heath Ledger.
Take him,
if he take you to that,
check them in your eyes.
Take him,
take him.
Take Heath Ledger and imagine if heath
ledger had oded on heroin.
Remember when God,
what?
Phoenix.
Now River Phoenix,
the great actor.
He sell coal blind.
Seymour Hoffman,
right?
Right.
One of the news stories is how they're
trying to find his dealer.
Right?
They're like,
we're going to hunt down the guy who
sold in this fucking shitty smack,
but when he fletcher,
Oh,
d's on these fucking pills.
You don't hear anybody being like,
we're going to find the pharmacists that
gave heath ledger this combination of
fucking pills and we're going to take
this son of a bitch down.
It's just like,
wow.
It was pills.
So it's heath ledger's thought that's
not the pharmacist,
but.
So does.
Very good point.
Yeah.
It's just very,
very good to take you.
It's like,
let's acknowledge the fact that if you
are dealing drugs,
you're a drug dealer and whatever the
drug is that you're dealing,
uh,
whether it's sanctioned by the state or
not sanctioned by the state,
whatever that drug is,
that you're,
uh,
dealing,
it is the decision of the person who
buys it from you to take it.
It is their own freewill.
It is human autonomy.
If you decide to take a substance that
is your right as a human,
no matter what the fuck it is from God
damn heroin to marijuana,
to alcohol,
your right as a human being on this
planet is to,
as much as you want,
alter or transform your particular
chemical states or psychological states
or mood states even if it ends up
killing you,
but your but,
but under the effects of those things,
you're not allowed to hurt other people.
You're not allowed to do fucked up shit.
And if you do,
those are the laws and the crimes that
you should be.
How the candidates,
oh,
for Hunter Thompson had a set of rules
that he was trying to establish when he
was running for mayor of Aspen in the 19
seventies and one of the things was he
was going to have stock hades.
He was gonna.
He was gonna sign up to all the streets,
like chew up all the concrete,
saw the streets,
and he was going to have stock that he
would put drug dealers so that he said
that any drug worth taking you should
never buy or sell of rule four rule is
what we going to.
What he was going to do was he was
gonna.
Well obviously it wasn't really going to
do that.
I mean it was pros,
but he was saying that he was going to
have stock hades in front of the
statehouse where he would,
or front of the building,
whatever it would be.
Wow.
He's great man.
Great.
What is his.
He's got another quote.
I just read what I just,
I love.
Which is like,
you don't find lsd.
LSD finds you when you're ready.
It's true.
It's pretty cool,
man.
I don't believe that.
I believe that with all psychedelics.
I really do.
It sounds so stupid when you say it.
Like you believe it,
bro.
You believe it was a plan for
everything.
It doesn't matter if I believe or don't
believe because I really would never
know if it's true,
but it's fun to believe it,
so therefore I believe it.
I don't really think that the Hulk Bruce
Banner becomes the hulk and leaps
through the air and smashes the
airplanes,
but it's fun.
It's fun to watch it and while it's
happening I try to pretend like it's
really happened,
man.
Damn right.
That's a problematic.
You know,
I think a lot of skeptics and cynics
does sound on fun.
They don't understand that it's that
like they were.
I believe that I can choose whatever
lens I want to use to look through the
universe.
They're super important to men because
they dispelled bullshit and then the
comforter,
the comfort that you have in balancing
on the ledge of truth and fantasy and
fun,
and some people do not have that comfort
on that ledge and for them,
skeptics are hugely important because
they can disprove a lot of the shit that
other folks can't see.
Everybody has different vision when it
comes to their ability to perceive
things and some are born shortsighted,
but we're supposed to pretend that the
brain is 100 percent equal across the
board and everyone can see all the
bullshit that everyone else can see.
Well,
that's not always the case.
There's some people that just don't have
good sight and they don't have good
clarity there.
They just don't and they need help.
Well,
yeah,
they do.
You're right,
but those people aren't gonna.
Listen to a fucking skeptic.
I mean data.
If they need a little,
some of them will.
There's,
there's a spectrum of them,
but,
but I do think you are as a skeptic in
the same way,
like I will fully admit that many
fantasies that I have many ideas that I
have a completely unprovable and more
than likely horse shit,
but they're so fun.
They're so fun.
But here's another thing that's
important to acknowledge is that some of
the lenses that you look through the
universe through,
even if the symbols that are within
those lenses are completely ridiculous,
like the symbol of Jesus rising from the
dead,
for example,
or the symbol of a ganache or the symbol
of Honamin.
Uh,
even though the symbols themselves are
clearly a fantasy,
the effect of gazing through those
lenses and the effect that it has on the
decisions that you make quite often can
be really profound.
Which is that instead of making selfish,
stupid,
angry decisions,
you might start making more positive
decisions because you've connected with
this architect,
archetypical God of friendship and
devotion,
which is who Honamin as you know,
Hanuman's.
This monkey God that represents like
pure devotion or service and friendship
at the deepest,
sweetest level to.
And it's beautiful,
it's beautiful,
and so I can use that symbol if I want
to,
uh,
when I'm thinking about loyalty or when
I'm thinking about like giving up my
life for another person's life.
When I think about like giving myself to
another person with nothing really to
gain other than giving myself to that
person and helping them as I can.
It's a great symbol.
It works.
Doesn't have to be fucking real.
Do I believe in a monkey?
God that flies through the sky?
Do I believe in that?
Do you think that symbols would,
they can be,
is almost like dedicated,
dedicated thoughts that you can cling
onto if you're trying to explain this,
if you're moving through a sea of being
a person,
all the variables,
all the negatives and positives and the,
the,
the changing of the tide,
of your emotions and your happiness and
your discontent and your depression
will.
But you could have these islands that in
this float you could cling to and one of
them might be the Buddha.
Yes.
And when you see the Buddha,
you think of enlightenment.
You think of yourself at peace and they
can somehow or another imbibe you imbibe
view with this,
this,
this cap encapsulization of like you're
like,
you're at least your imaginary
idea of what it's like to be
enlightened.
Damn right,
you clean,
you clean to that and that I can maybe
guide you a little.
You could hold onto that and it'll carry
you down and maybe from there you can
get to dry land.
Maybe from there you can get to the
island of new ideas,
but these,
these archetypal things that you claim
to these,
these images,
whatever they may be,
the reason why they've existed
throughout history as that people have
found value in their memories and
connecting thoughts and principles and
ideas to these symbols and that's why
they defend them so hard.
That's why people want to kill you.
If you draw Muhammad,
if you fuck up their idea of their
symbol,
their symbol is so significant to them
that they're willing to.
If they're willing to lash out and
caused murder because you violated
their.
They got stuck on the assemble and
that's the.
That's a problem.
It's like somebody going through the
wilderness thinking that the campus is
the destination and it's,
you know,
that's.
I don't know how anyone would be that
dumb to think that and so that's a wrong
way to put it,
but it's a really.
It's a in the same way literally like
people who are always fighting over the
literal g or the historic Jesus,
you know,
the people are like,
that guy didn't even fucking exist,
and that people that get really caught
up and disproving Jesus,
they've also gotten caught up in the
surface level of that symbol and so
they're spending all their time trying
to prove no,
no,
no.
There's never was a historic Jesus or
the historic Jesus that existed was not
the Jesus in the Bible that has blah,
whatever you want to say.
You're damn right you,
I,
I'll buy a shirt.
There was no real Jesus or there was.
He was one of many people or who knows,
or maybe he wasn't magical or whatever
on one level,
fuck yes,
you're 100 percent right.
There's also no Santa Claus.
There's no such thing as ghosts.
There's no such thing as reincarnation,
we're all just a non-differentiated
aspect of a great mass of Adam's
currently being exploded out of an event
13 point 8 billion years ago,
and that's it.
Nothing else.
That's fucking it.
That's one level and it's totally real.
There's another level though.
That's the problem.
There is a completely other level which
is that the level of the interior self,
the level of the subjective,
the universe did a big bang.
It exploded from the.
It did a big bang.
It exploded.
I did a big duty like God is a baby,
just accidentally shit Outta universe,
but it explodes out and then it ends up
turning into human beings and human
beings end up somehow developing this
incredibly advanced for frontal lobe and
the neo cortex.
Whenever you can throw out that word,
throw it out,
it makes you seem smart.
Couldn't have a neocortex walked out to
me.
I wouldn't know what it looked like,
but.
But when that happened,
we.
We gained an interior universe,
which is the universe of symbols,
myth,
dreams,
stories,
and that's a real part of the material
universe.
The material universe has a substrata,
which is the universe of myth and the
universe of religion and the universe of
fantasy,
and that's another level of the fucking
thing,
and if you start tuning into those
symbols,
it doesn't matter if you're tuning into
an externalized,
mystical,
super entity or whether you're tuning
into a part of your brain that it comes
from millions of years of evolution.
You're still tuning into a point where
from a harmonizing with it,
you can experience an elevated mood
state and that elevated mood,
state and whatever way it manifests from
the,
uh,
experience of Samadhi to the experience
of the passion of the Christ,
the surrender to allowing yourself to be
destroyed by time and still loving it.
Or a yoga class or a comedy club or
being the see a concert.
Yeah,
be you see a concert and you seeing
someone perform music or someone was
really good that you really appreciate
their art.
It moves you,
you're holding,
your body feels different,
your emotions get torn up.
You're like,
wow.
Like people will cry when they hear a
great song though.
There'll be moved like the like,
fuck yeah,
they'll throw their hands in the air to
get nutty.
The body will start moving,
the Kinnaman help it or a mantra or a
mantra or a mantra or or or any number
of things that you can lock into with or
sounds or images or some thing that we
have encapsulated that causes us to
react in this incredible way that we can
replicate shot through the shoe,
gave him a bad name and everybody just
goes fucking crazy whether or not you
agree with Bon Jovi or not.
That moment where 15,000
freaks go crazy.
Yeah,
because he sinks,
shot through the heart and you're to
blame and they just lose their shit.
They can't help but they're stomping.
They're hugging each other like,
oh my God,
they're high fiving each other.
It's the best.
Like it's undeniable that that gave
those 15,000
people,
you know,
step out of the role of being an art
critic for a moment and look at what
happened to those 15,000
people.
It's like,
that's how I have to do with the
grateful dead.
I've,
I've always had to step outside of the
role of a music critic and just
appreciate the.
Some people love the fuck out of them.
Like,
okay,
I'm missing a gene or something.
No,
you've never taken acid and listening to
the grateful dead.
You gotta do man,
take some acid and listening to the
grateful dead with me.
You'll understand dude.
I smoked DMT and listened to eco rose
with Aubrey.
Wow.
And that.
I don't know if the grateful dead and
acid is going to be able to fuck with
eco rose and the DMT experience.
You have to do that.
By the way.
I would like to try.
That is very different.
The ECO rose thing is very different.
This is what
mechanic was saying that these Shamans,
they sing for things into form.
They did.
You see like a visual representation.
It's perfectly sinked.
They're one in the same.
There are two different things that go
together and buy their own on their own.
They're are magical.
I mean on own.
Did the ECO
sound fucking amazing?
I listened to them on my way home from
gigs when I want to see what I want to
think about things,
but I also want to hear something
because I don't know what the fuck
they're saying so because I don't know
what they're saying.
I can enjoy it without being attached to
the words.
They're just a bunch of noises.
To me,
the cool noises and I know guys and only
because I know that word Iowasca I have.
I've got a guy.
It's really we.
It sounds like a little kid singing
kind.
It doesn't act like a little kid and the
forest would just be singing that song.
There's a lot of them that are like
that.
Yeah.
There's a lot of them that are really
interesting.
What is that?
Is that blowing the smoke?
Yeah.
I listen to this one.
I whistle this one.
I find myself like whistling it through
the day and the other day
I was whistling at the comedy store and
one of the dudes who works there started
whistling on.
It was weird.
He knew it.
Nope.
What?
I was doing it so much.
I was doing it so much,
it sort of snuck into them,
so the idea behind it,
according to the Shaman is that the
plants give them their salt and that as
they're cooking up,
the IOWASCA did learn the song and they
figured out through this relationship,
this pure relationship that they have to
the madre because they're a real sharp
and over the,
you know,
thousands of years of them doing this.
They found some songs and when you,
when you experienced dmt under the spell
of the songs is a very,
very strange experience because they,
they belong together.
It's like when you're hearing this,
every time it changes and there's a
whistle,
a new chapter,
we'll start a new geometric pattern will
explode into something completely
different and dance around you
and there's like a whole series that you
listened to when you're on a trip,
you start off with one sort of an
introductory one and you move into the
other one.
And as it goes deeper and deeper and
deeper that the experience changes and
becomes this like really crazy complex
geometrical life form that's all
encompassing.
It's everything that's all around you.
That's beautiful.
It's very strange,
dude.
That gets in the background.
That's legit as fuck,
man.
This is all recorded during a ceremony,
so this is not just happening like with
the guy singing happening,
there's a guy singing with a group of
people tripping the fucking balls off
and he's guiding them and while this is
going on,
like it dances all around you and sues
you and Tom to you and explained to you,
do you know what even trippier about
this
is that that night when you ever was
lived near this shrimping,
they're fucking brains.
I bet somebody thought,
man,
why do I feel like this is gonna get
transmitted to 10 million people?
How weird is that?
How weird is it that that's a very
strange thing.
That's what technology does because here
you consider this incredible night.
God knows where that was probably where.
Where do you think that was recorded?
Who the fuck knows?
Somewhere I'll have an experiment that I
want to do what?
I'm going to have crash rig my tank up
with speakers.
I want to listen to that in the tank
because I think if I listened to that in
a tank enough,
I think if I put that on loop for like
an hour,
I think I could trip my balls off.
I think I'm going to try that experiment
to.
Yeah.
Well you have a tank.
No,
you fucking fucking tag now.
I got his intent now.
It's so cool.
I'm A.
I'm a zen 10.
Explained to me the situation.
It's in a bedroom.
Well,
yeah.
What it is is because you know,
like a Cemati tanker,
any of the crashes,
tanks,
they're fucking crazy giant things and
take a while to sell.
They're expensive.
Right?
So yeah,
this is just like a essentially like a
reversed waterbed I guess you'd say.
It's like it's a,
it's a,
it's a tent.
A that how many gallons of water.
I don't know the exact gallons,
but it's big enough to float and fine.
Like because I floated out in Austin at
the Float Institute and the upload is
amazing.
Amazing.
The presses right up there with crashes
place and if you done crashes place.
I haven't done that yet.
Crashes the grandmaster,
but this guy who's got the tank place in
Austin.
Yeah,
Kevin,
what's it called?
Float Float Institute Institute.
He's got his things are built like
boats,
like the hub of a boat trailer.
Yeah.
Those things are super durable.
They don't even know liner there.
They're fucking cool man are super high
tech.
Super High Tech.
But the,
you know,
the essence of the thing is you've got a
shit ton of salt and water and you only
need a certain amount of room,
you know,
based on like the average size of a
human being.
Plenty of room in the damn things.
But yeah,
I just uh,
like I didn't realize how much I would
enjoy having a float tank in my house.
Like it.
I had no idea that it would be that
important to me.
I've only had it for a few days and
weeks lived with me.
You use it all the time and I forget
exactly.
But.
And it was awesome to have access,
but I was so brokenhearted and crazy
back then.
Like now it's just like,
you know,
I've been working out,
I'll go workout at the gym,
come back to the house with sore muscles
and then you're just,
regardless of all the mystical shit,
you're floating in 650 pounds of epsom
salt with sore muscles and that feels
damn good.
No,
it feels like you're charging batteries.
It's really amazing.
And you walk out of the thing every time
so far,
and I've done 30 minute floats up to
like an hour and a half so far.
Every time you get out of the thing,
it's exactly like the next day after a
great mushroom trip where colors are
brighter,
you just rested.
It's super cool,
man.
I'm super.
I can't.
I'm so and I haven't even gotten to the
point of like,
all right,
what happens if I take a microdose of
some psychoactive in this thing?
I haven't even gotten there yet.
You do that though,
right?
Way To respond to that question.
My favorite is eating pot.
If I,
if I ever ate too much pot and I was
sitting around the house,
I jumped in and right immediately.
I don't want to waste it.
Yeah,
man.
That's what I mean.
I guess that's a.
of course I've been eating pot and going
into.
Of course I'm always eating pot.
Said the other day on stage,
but when you brought me up on stage and
the night of the ice house,
I was like,
Duncan is the only guy that will tell
me,
man,
I got.
I fucking did acid.
I'm not.
I mean I did.
Emma will do mtms.
I did ecstasy.
I'm not doing that anymore,
man.
I'm fucking.
I haven't did anything for awhile.
She's eating weed everyday.
That's it.
Like basically fucking almost sober.
I consider that.
I know this is.
This is gonna seem like denial.
I'm sorry.
For those addicts out there.
Maybe I'm in denial,
but to me it does feel like coffee.
Like I place it in the same place.
I put coffee so it's not really to me
like it does.
It's like something that I,
I don't find to be destructive to my
life at all.
I think alcohol was the monster and
marijuana seems to just be a kind of,
well I'll do it one better.
I worshiped coffee,
right.
Worship bit.
Coffee is a ritual.
I have a ritual when I write and I have
a ritual when I do podcasts and one of
my.
One of the big parts of my ritual is
coffee,
not like a monster energy drink.
I mean,
I don't have anything wrong.
I don't.
Not like red bowls.
They're fine.
If you just need a pick me up.
I'll drink wine.
If I'm at the store and I know I'm tired
and I have to drive home,
I'll take a red bull,
but a coffee is like a ritual.
I adore coffee.
I really do like,
I love to get like a nice warm cup of
coffee and then I started writing and I
do what I do.
A podcast like for me,
the podcast doesn't seem like it starts
until I'd take a sip of coffee.
Right.
So I love it.
I love coffee.
I like the feeling,
what it gives to me.
I liked the way it tastes.
I feel the same way about pond.
I love it.
It's.
I don't,
I don't.
Not only do I not think,
I absolutely don't think it's
detrimental.
I adore it and I think it helps my life.
I adore it.
I don't have any negatives.
I've figured me and pot of a fucking
super good relationship and sometimes it
leaves me tired and I can't remember
exactly what I just said,
but it provides me with so much
inspiration and introspective thinking
that the,
the,
the counter,
like the payoff is huge
man.
Huge.
You add to that having a fucking hole in
the universe,
in your goddamn house.
Get out of town,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
I've been saying it forever.
Don't know.
What have I been telling you for years?
You have to take God dammit.
Donkey.
Yeah.
You would say that to me.
Like when I was like,
you would say it to me when I car's
about to get repossessed.
Like,
oh,
just get a flow.
Okay.
I
told you anytime you wanted to get,
use mine,
you know that know you well yeah,
of course you have the keys to my house.
You can come over 3:00
in the morning and he's my tank anytime
you don't wake my kids up fucking
Weirdo.
How weird would that would be a Weirdo
come daddy.
The weirdos here again,
the climate here,
uncle,
Uncle Duncan,
but man that.
Yeah,
it's a.
it's a beautiful town.
Beautiful happens and I think they
should have community centers that have
a man.
I mean,
so there's a lot of people that have
apartments and in their apartment they
have [inaudible].
They have a stationary bike or a
treadmill.
They have a little small gym with a
television set in there.
You want to have a nice apartment,
an apartment.
The fucking float tank can use.
You have someone who maintains it.
People sign up for it.
Don't let just anybody use it.
Make sure that the guy who runs into
creepers,
I'm going to peek in on chicks whether
in there naked,
put a lock on the door,
make sure you know these people are
going to shit in it.
There's no way around it.
He'll.
You'll know who did it.
They have to sign up,
right the fuck that guy will the victim
that's you get evicted from the
apartment complex to fight on top of the
apartment conflict area manager.
So went shit in that water.
It doesn't matter how many times they
filter it,
you're not getting all this shit out.
You have to take all the water out and
clean the whole thing that water.
The next time you climb in and there's
going to be something in there that
bites yet,
what do you think the number is
worldwide of people that have taken big
shifts in isolation tanks?
Thousand Dollars.
Imagine if there was a compilation video
of every person who has ever taken a
shit inside the isolation tank and you
can just watch it happen in real time.
People are awful.
You would.
You'd be insisting that people are awful
and I think that's one of the real
problems with judging the human beings
as a,
as a race.
So there's too many of us.
So if there's 7 billion people it,
while we're saying this,
50 dudes are shitting and tanks right
now,
for sure,
right?
This tanks aren't even that common.
There's not that many tanks in the
world,
but if people don't like the best over
the course of this podcast,
I'll say over the course of this
podcast,
and that's a conservative estimate
taking how many fucking idiots there
are.
That just shit their pants.
How many people are there?
They're so stupid.
They just shit their pants all the time
necessarily a measurement of Iq.
They shit their bed.
They,
you know,
when I was in,
I had to,
I had a girlfriend.
I've told this story before,
but it's very unfortunate.
And her roommate,
um,
used to have anal sex with her boyfriend
and she wrote a letter about it that the
reason why he does it,
he's a little dick and it doesn't feel
good unless he puts it in her ass and
like it's very sobering for this poor
gentleman and found this letter or her,
her diary or whatever,
but shit,
the bed when they,
they had,
they had anal sex and apparently it
relaxed her sphincter to the point where
she just relaxed in bed while sleeping
and just shat in the bed.
And Yeah.
And like the dude was just standing in
the hallway like a random,
like I came out of my girlfriend's
bedroom and he was there in the hall of
his hands out.
Like after she had just shit on him.
He was like,
what the fuck?
I never forget this poor,
poor
what the fuck someone just shit on him
because he was having anal sex with this
girl he released.
So what I'm saying is that poor gal,
with whatever damage he did to her
butthole,
she could probably shit the bed if she
went to an isolation tank,
you know,
she wasn't paying attention.
She got a little too relaxed and fell
asleep in there.
You can get your bed,
you can shit an isolation tank area can
and people shit the bed.
They just do.
Yeah,
I mean they do.
There's no way around it.
I,
I get,
I guess I think of like if you were in
there and like you had just blasted some
academy and into your bloodstream or
south thing and you were just really
gone and maybe your body will just
evacuate it's bowels because it wanted
to,
you know,
your astral body is,
who knows where you're on Venus,
you're not even in the float tank.
You're,
you're just a monkey in there now.
Yeah,
I would imagine that's definitely,
probably happened to somebody that took
some drug.
Did you,
um,
have you talked to Neal Brennan at all?
Do you know Neil?
I know Neil,
but I haven't talked to him.
Wait,
I've got to take a leak.
Please go ahead.
Go ahead and do it.
And when you come back,
I'll return to you,
its customer with your priestly priestly
outfit.
When you return,
I'll tell you about neal Brennan taking
ketamine for therapy.
Did you know about that?
Come,
come back young Jesus.
What are you a bishop or some shit?
He's a bishop.
Duncan trussell.
Uh,
Bishop,
uh,
if you,
have never listened at Duncan trussell's
podcasts and you're tuning into this,
maybe this is the first podcast here,
we listened to the Duncan trussell
family hour is for real,
like probably one of the best podcasts
in the known universe and Duncan is a,
an oddly articulate and very bizarre
character that I don't know anybody like
him,
you know,
and he has a very interesting and unique
way of looking at shit.
And one of the reason why I like doing
podcasts with them because I feel like
that when Duncan and I get together,
we both pull some weird part out of each
other.
That's what I felt like when we were
doing that stupid Scifi show when we
were talking to people about bigfoot and
shit.
But that's how I feel when I do any
podcasts with him.
He's just a very,
very unusual dude.
And His standup is fucking hilarious and
he will be with me at the comedy store
this Friday night.
We're doing the belly room at 10:00.
I don't even think the tickets are
available yet,
but this Friday night at the belly room
at 10:00,
it would just be me and Duncan.
That's it.
And it's only like 70 tickets so it
sells out very quick.
So,
uh,
if you're interested in,
I'm doing Saturday night at the same
time to,
at 10:00.
So that's it.
Fuckers,
Duncan trussell family hour is on
itunes.
He doesn't have any standup that you can
buy unfortunately.
And that's something I've been hounding
Dunkin for the longest.
Fucking timely enters his little girl
bladder.
It's one thing I've learned about
myself,
young Jamie from doing this podcast and
I have a manly bladder.
I can drink four cups of coffee and sit
here for three fucking hours and not
bitch out and make them mad.
Run for the bathroom most days,
most days.
But I've had some,
I've had some bad days,
I've had some days where I couldn't keep
it together.
Sister,
part of being a person.
So if you can please give Duncan the
hardest time possible about putting
together a goddamn comedy specials so
you all can enjoy his standup,
his brother.
Praise,
praise,
praise zoo.
Save tour,
man.
Big Tour.
It's happening.
I can't talk about it.
My amazing agent,
Joe Schwartz,
the secret.
They're going to be good though.
It's happening.
It is happening.
Do.
When were you doing some gigs together
again?
We haven't done gigs,
but we're doing Friday night at the
comedy store,
but we got to do some good gigs.
I now go away from Los Angeles.
Tuck.
Yeah friend.
Let's do travel.
Yeah,
let's travel.
Love to.
We need to do something where we do we
do a series of dates on the road.
You and I.
This is what I'm thinking.
Go to these different towns and then go
do cool shit in the town and film it.
Like,
let's go to an Ashram.
Let's,
uh,
let's take a yoga class together.
Let's do a bunch of shit.
Is Weird Shit.
Specific to the task.
Let's float tank and every time.
Yeah,
let's go to the Kentucky Derby.
I want to do the Kentucky Derby next
year and do a standup show in town.
I want to know what the fuck that's all
about.
Horse racing was not even about the
race,
so at everybody getting fucked up.
That's what it's about,
right?
My Buddy Cameron hanes went this year
and you're like,
Jesus Christ.
He's like,
it's just people just getting drunk like
everywhere you go.
Everyone is just plowed by a hunter.
Thompson.
One of his early pieces of work that got
him notoriety was he did a bit on the
Kentucky Derby.
The Kentucky Derby is decadent and
deprived and his store in the Kentucky
Derby.
It's fascinating because it starts out
just just describing the heinous people
around them and then realizing you're
one of those people.
At the end he realized he's one of the
monsters that he's been describing.
That's awesome,
but it's just one of those things.
It's been going on forever and it's like
connected to this ancient culture of
riverboat gamblers.
You know?
I mean,
that's what the Kentucky Derby is like.
The ultimate gambler experience.
Drunken excess.
It's like mint Juleps.
It's that.
It's getting hammered and it's horse
races,
but it's like this,
it's like a social event where people go
and have a great time and apparently the
vibe there is incredible.
Like it's like really fun,
like chaotic and people do just get
fucking shit faced shit faced and I
think if we went and got shit faced with
these people.
Yeah.
That can be super fun man.
I mean there's places to go get shit
faced out.
Right?
Right,
right.
But I want to experience the Kentucky
Derby.
The Kentucky Derby is something that
I've heard of.
I don't know enough about.
Even like,
yeah,
sure.
Like why don't we do that man.
We could just go to burning man.
Isn't that large?
A bunch of horses gallop around
alcoholics.
When you go to the middle of the desert
where there's shooting laser beams into
space and giant squid tanks are rolling
by shooting fire or we could do both.
That's impossible.
That's not the.
That's on different dates now.
I know I'm joking.
Can do both.
Yeah.
That's what we should've done for.
So to you and me looking for a
nonexistent unknown primate wandering
through the woods of the Pacific
northwest,
we should have gone to raves.
We should have found real freaks.
I don't understand why,
you know,
I don't understand.
Yeah,
you're right.
There's so many other ways to like
analyze the universe.
Like we're as far as science goes or
somebody who's going to do a scientific
investigation if things were pretty far
away from the ideal scientist and we
weren't really doing science and we're
looking for bigfoot bullshit detecting
where you really are doing now.
But I,
you know what I mean man.
I think that it's like what,
what ends up happening?
Because TV shows have got to like having
to wrap everything up.
You got to have a point.
You got to have a thing.
You can't do what a podcast dies,
which is just whatever you want.
And I can't they do that.
I don't know.
I guess I don't know.
I mean why can't they have like a late
night show that,
why don't they have a late night show
look after and I chose over.
That just goes on for like three hours.
I don't know,
I'm just.
It's just two dudes talking or whatever
and a guest and talk.
No band.
No,
you're a fucking band.
Come on.
What are you a baby and I need to play
music for you.
I think people would take great comfort
in that,
but the problem is you can't do it
because of the way TV works.
Every single thing that anybody says on
tv,
he's got to go through a filter and
that's the,
what do you call it,
the regulatory bureau that makes sure
people say that.
People say things that aren't like curse
words or what's that called?
There's a name for it.
Standards and practices,
so everything has to run through that.
So I think that the idea of having.
And you could do it on Hbo,
I guess you'd have to have it on a.
on a non a public station.
It needs to be a subscription TV
station.
You could probably pull that off,
but you can't do it on NBC.
You can't have people talk for three
hours because inevitably somebody is
going to start really saying the truth
or they're going to start saying a truth
that doesn't fit in with selling cell
phones in mass,
and that's going to be.
They're not going to like that.
When you do stand up on those shows,
you've got to show them your set,
right?
They analyze every line,
every sentence,
every word gets analyzed.
You have to show them like a written
transcript of things are going to say.
Can you imagine if we tried to show a
network this transcript of what we
talked about here today,
like the notes,
how many I.
I imagined that we would get over 7,000
pages of notes back.
I bet the notes that we get would be 500
times longer than the episode itself.
Did I ever tell you that?
My friend Amir was a writer on the
early,
early days of Conan.
Now through a lot of comics wrote for
Conan in the early,
early days,
and my friend Amir,
Amir Golan,
he was,
his name is James Lemur.
That was a stage name.
Really Funny Dude from Boston,
he and so I was there for the early,
early filmings when I was like,
you know,
I guess I was like kind of working maybe
like just starting to work and go,
well I didn't have any money and I was
told scrub,
but I was his friends.
I went to botch and they,
they all,
the Andy Richter,
Conan O'brien interactions were
scripted.
One hundred percent scripted.
They had cue cards above them so they
weren't talking.
They were fake.
They're fake talking like,
like if you and I,
we're going to talk about this right now
and it would have all this shit that I
was going to say already written out and
it was a sign behind each other,
like a sign behind the Indian guy
holding the sign behind Kona because
we're talking about like 1990 or some
shit.
When did the Conan O'brien show start?
What year did the Conan O'brien show
start?
I'm going to say like 91 or 92.
Somewhere around there.
That's if I had to guess at the latest,
I could think it'd be like 93.
But it was weird.
Weird.
It's really weird.
It's like you're watching pirates of the
Caribbean or something,
so it's straight,
but they don't do that anymore.
Thank God.
But I mean he had to go to fucking tbs
to probably get rid of the 93.
There we go.
That was pretty close.
Yeah.
I don't get that man.
I mean it's so I,
I can't wait for that to change.
That's.
TV's going to get so much better.
They don't do that anymore.
Nobody does.
Nobody does that.
They did that because he was a writer
who did that because he was a writer.
They really didn't have a performance
background and all of a sudden he was
hosting this late night talk show
because he was so funny because in
writer's rooms,
Conan O'brien would just smash.
He was the guy.
He was so fucking funny and his jokes
were so good that in writer's rooms they
will like Jesus Christ,
you should be a fucking comic.
Like should be.
You should be the host of a show.
And then the next thing you know,
a bunch of people got behind him and
they said,
listen,
we're gonna bankroll him.
I'll have him do the guy.
And you know,
once he loosened up and got used to the
role,
I mean,
you know,
he became like one of a lot of people's
favorite.
Watching the early show and watching
them do it.
Like what a script.
It was very enlightenment.
What would you do this as a late night
show to.
I'm sure you've gotten.
Someone has got.
Must've come to you by now.
This is early morning show.
It's a late night show.
It's a mid afternoon show.
It's available whenever you want it.
It's 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
And.
But do you ever think about like how,
how often do you think about translating
it to the TV environment or something?
Never.
Almost never.
You must get pitched all the time.
No,
I don't know.
I don't even,
I don't even take pitches.
I don't want to do anything other than
what I'm doing right now.
I've thought about it before and you
know the,
the experience of doing the spike TV
thing,
the Scifi thing rather.
What was fun was doing with you.
That's what it was.
Fun.
That was what was fun,
but it's not fun dealing with all those
other people.
Not The people that we worked with.
Although the producers on that side were
great and a lot of people in the
networks that were great,
but there were so many voices.
It wasn't even that they were bad folks.
You're dealing with too many people in
it.
Everybody's got discrepancies and I
think it should go like this and maybe
you should try that.
Or maybe you can come in here.
Maybe he could dress different.
Maybe you could hold that or maybe you
could stand there like,
fuck man.
There's too many of you talking like,
look,
we're trying to make the best thing,
but you're not the person that's going
to like figure me out.
Okay.
I've got a good sense of who I am and if
you want me to wear a suit and tie and
you think it's going to change.
If I come in on a parachute or if I step
out of a fucking flaming Hula Hoop,
we're talking crazy.
I don't want to do that.
Like if I had,
if I want to sit down with some comedy
writers and bounce around some ideas,
I don't want a year to many people's
voices and that.
I mean it's their prerogative.
I mean if you're,
if you're on a television show or
somebody wants to pay for it,
right?
And it's not you.
So it's their prerogative to do that.
But I don't want to be.
I don't,
I just don't think I operate the best
doing that.
Right.
I don't think this podcast would have
ever occurred if I had a boss who would
have never happened now and most of this
shit I would've never said and I would
have to like debate who the guests were.
The idea of debating who the guests are
make me wants to.
I just want to throw up like the idea of
have to convince someone that Joey Diaz
should be on Tuesday.
I've got to convince them.
I know Joe has been on two months ago,
but it doesn't matter.
You need a black guy.
You need a black woman.
That's what you need on your podcast,
a black woman.
What we're looking at your diversity
statistics,
right?
I'm going to do what the fuck I want to
do and do whatever I want to do,
and the only way to do whatever you want
to do is to do your own thing.
As soon as you start doing it on
television,
you're not doing whatever you want to do
unless you become wildly successful like
south park,
to the point where they just leave you
the fuck alone and new regimes come and
go while you're still the king.
They just,
they don't say shit to Daniel Tosh.
Everybody just shuts the fuck up and
leaves them alone.
You don't want to fuck that up.
You got a monolithic show.
Lucky South Park.
It's been going on forever and it's just
as funny now as it's ever been.
Just stay the fuck away from them or
don't talk to them.
Don't ruin anything.
Are there any examples of a show where
they let them do whatever they want at
and the show failed because of it?
I'm sure.
I'm sure there have been no what it is.
I don't know.
There's got to be generally always here
with like Mr show or like a lot of the
great sketch groups or like any great
show.
One thing you always hear,
it's like they mostly just let us do
what we want it and it's the.
It's when the opposite effect happens.
Well,
that's what the Chappelle show.
That's what broke the Chappelle show up.
Dave Chappelle was like,
fuck this.
There's too many people telling them
what to do.
Saying them that he couldn't say certain
things,
couldn't you know?
There was a lot of money on the line for
that show.
He's talked about it.
He's talked about.
They wouldn't let him say the word
nigger.
Like there was a.
There was a real concern with him
continuing to say that word.
That's crazy.
And they were saying that if he didn't
say they could make more money in
advertising,
I would love to really sit down with him
and find out what was.
What was like,
what was the feeling when all that was
happening?
What was the feeling of being connected
to this cultural monster rage?
I was on it twice,
but I didn't.
I didn't really talk to them about.
It was in the time.
It was just like,
wow,
this is great.
Dane's got this awesome show.
That's hilarious.
Holy Shit.
Fuck.
I'd love to be on it.
It was one of those things.
It wasn't like,
like,
what is this like for you?
Like,
like now having the podcast.
I'd be like,
what is it?
What is the feeling of everywhere you
go.
I'm Rick James Pitch.
Yeah.
Did that fuck with you?
Because I know people used to heckle him
with that and it was like a real
problem.
Right?
Like people would heckle.
They would yell that out.
You know,
everybody was yelling out,
I'm Rick James Bitch.
It was ridiculous.
They got to the point where they would
yell it out and he couldn't even compete
continuous show because like dumb white
kids,
it'd be yelling out,
I'm Rick James Bitch.
So bad.
It's so fucked up is that.
But obviously he made it through it,
but the point being what a weird
experience that must have been just to
be a human being,
to be at the tip of the comedy spear
like that for a while and then have a
bunch of people fuck with it.
Have a bunch of people just wouldn't
make David.
You need to listen to David,
David two lane.
Uh,
Mr Chappelle thing about all the money
you're leaving on the table.
How many people telling him what words
to use.
And not to say that don't be yourself.
No,
no,
no.
We need to do,
to be a little better packaged.
We're trying to make money here.
David's right.
We're trying to make money.
And so he walked away like a gangster
from some,
like $50 million dollar deal.
That's right.
Good.
See Ya.
Integrity.
That guy's got serious integrity man.
Through his,
through his pores.
How many people would down a lot of
people who would not walk me?
Yeah.
Would be like the n word.
It's unimportant.
You know?
I think bill crosby wants to saying
that.
I'm like,
yeah,
I was thinking I definitely wanted it
for a second.
What I was thinking for a second,
I was thinking of like other people in
my mind I'm going to be like,
yeah,
they definitely wouldn't work him.
And I'm like judgmental shit.
Fucking top of it,
Paul.
If people walk away,
you as I look,
I hosted fear factor.
Sure.
I'll change my name.
What'd you want to call me?
Yeah,
sure.
Senior poopy pants shall be senior boot.
Oh yeah,
I'll share.
I'll go into the float tanks and someone
just shit it ain't no prob mats me Senor
poopy pants for Citibank.
Mastercard.
Citibank.
Mastercard is the best mastercard.
It's the one senior poopy pants.
Use it.
Why not?
You know what?
But why he wasn't Chappelle.
Kind of
like wasn't,
isn't he?
I don't know if he's still is busy.
Kind of like an illuminati believer,
like aren't there interviews with him
where he kind of talks about,
well look,
I don't know.
I haven't had these conversations with
him personally,
so I don't know the full extent of his
beliefs,
but he believes in some shit that's
real.
Like the Bilderberg group,
the fact that these industrial,
it's really do get together and meet and
try
to figure out how to continue running
the world the way it's run right now
because they're extracting massive
amounts of money from it.
I mean that's real.
We know that the Bilderberg group,
those are real meetings.
We know that the federal bank.
Okay.
W We know how that works.
We know that the federal bank isn't
bank.
It's not federal.
It's just it's a privately owned
company.
We know that international banks and as
well as well as the banks in this
country have all done all sorts of
horrible shit involving laundering money
and gotten little slaps on the wrist and
a little baby fines and when they're
about to fall apart,
our own tax dollars are used to step in
and save these fuckheads.
We all know all that,
yet we all know that.
We just sort of accept it.
Yeah.
Kennedy shot in broad daylight.
There's so much of what it is to be a
person that runs a government that no
one other than that person or those
people is ever going to understand.
I think it's probably like a helpless
position where you realize once you get
there like,
Oh God,
this isn't.
Nobody does this.
Right.
It can't be done.
Literally can't be done.
I'm going to try to do my best to get
some healthcare pushed through some
other,
some other things.
Maybe gay marriage,
gay marriage on the books.
Fuck Yeah,
man,
that guy's having a great week.
Great Week.
He really is.
Yeah.
I,
you know.
Yeah.
I don't know.
We don't know.
That is the belief that the president
has a kind of hapless victim that gets
pulled into a web of darkness and does
the best that he can do is certainly
more comforting than the other version
of the story,
which is that it's just somebody who's a
narcissist to trick themselves into
thinking they were some capital is Jesus
and then they're going to walk across
the stage of history and create
incredible changes for the better in the
world while hoping to God that the
people you're creating the changes for.
We'll forget about the countless
children you've transformed into
hamburger meat
from dropping bombs at a drop drawings
on top of them accidentally and they we
do because maybe it is a game.
You start thinking,
is it.
This is like a game of thrones style
universe where you know every decision
that you make are five percent of the
decisions you make are going to result
in someone dying and someone not dying
and you're forced into the predicament
of saying,
wow.
I guess if I have to pick between dying
and not dying,
I'm going to pick people from the
country.
I'm currently the president of over the
people from the country.
I'm not the president of.
That's going to be the decision I have
to make because that's the oath that
I've sworn.
So yeah,
from time to time I'm going to,
I'm going to explode some fucking kids
and I'm also gonna get gay marriage
legalized and I'm also going to help
ease the prohibition on marijuana and
then once a month while
I will completely destroy a village.
Fuck that.
Fuck that job.
Indeed.
Jobs insane.
It's insane.
And being a cop and being a cop's
insane.
Saul.
Insane.
Well,
yeah.
jobs are insane,
but you got to suck it back down to your
job.
Like where you're at,
man.
I mean that's the thing.
Like my brain will go,
go in those directions so much,
you know?
Uh.
Did you see Obama or here Obama on
Marin?
I absolutely did.
I didn't hear it yet.
Good.
Oh,
that's a good interview,
man.
He did a great job,
I was super.
One of my favorite part of the
interview.
Uh,
one thing that happened,
I heard Marin on a bunch of interviews
afterwards because everybody's like,
what the fuck is that like to get to
interview the president?
And he was remarking on how Obama put
him at ease,
like how Obama was really good at
putting him at ease,
like it's his podcast,
but Obama,
just this master of like getting them to
relax and now so that he could do the
interview and not be nervous because you
could hear him at the beginning,
just like most people,
he said he sounded a little nervous as
you shouldn't use the fucking president
were secret service.
Uh,
all over your goddamn house they have,
they had to block the window out with
garbage bags because there was a sight
line where there could have been a
sniper on a roof.
There's a sniper on the roof of his
fucking house.
Man in his intro,
he's like,
there's a sniper up my roof.
My neighbors hate me.
They shut off the whole street.
Like they came to his house,
you know,
it came.
Why did he do it as house?
What did he just do it at a place where
they can secure it gets bad.
That's bad.
It's a bad ass decision because it's
about us.
They must have been like,
you know,
that they were like,
do we have to do it at your house?
And he must've been like,
we're going to do it at my fucking
house.
He did it.
He wore his flannel.
That was another bad decision.
Mark Marin Morris fucking flannel in the
United States.
No suit,
no change of attire.
That's,
that is his attire though.
That's his outfit.
Much like you're a bishop and I'm a NASA
guy.
That's right.
I will think about what you said.
He wore his flannel so he puts his out
sake.
You were like a grateful dead tee shirt
or a fucking wife.
But a lot of people,
they're like,
I'm in the president,
I'm going to present to the president,
I'm going to wear a Tuxedo or whatever.
But that dresses in his normal attire.
That was pretty cool.
And then,
um,
the interview itself was really great.
It was like,
it was like Obama was very funny and
they were,
it was like they're great funny moments
and that one of my favorite lines in the
interview was a Obama like mentions like
Mark Marin mentions black helicopters
and he's like,
but there's no black helicopters.
Right?
And Obama was like,
there are black helicopters,
they just are in other countries more
than we use them here.
But he did say they're black
helicopters.
It's kind of everybody knows that I
know.
But it was a funny thing for the
president to hear it out of the
president's mouth and it kind of funny
way.
But again,
man,
you know,
outside of the how incredibly
charismatic,
affable and how grateful I am to a lot
of the shit the Obama administration has
done healthcare.
And I know a lot
of people out there fucking hate what
he's done.
But as somebody who has had cancer,
knowing that if I wanted to get
insurance,
if my insurance lapsed or something and
they're not going to do what they
usually do,
which is a uh,
uh,
they would investigate you before you
couldn't get insurance for days and days
and days.
They would investigate you to find out
if you have previous health conditions
and you couldn't get insurance so you'd
have to,
like,
you could die or you get shitty
healthcare.
Uh,
it's cool to know that a lot of people
don't have to deal with that shit.
I think it's cool.
I know it's not a perfect system and
from a libertarian perspective,
I,
I know a lot of you probably have good
reasons to really hate it,
but I think there's a lot of good
reasons to not hit it too.
So I'm grateful for that.
Marijuana seems to be becoming legal
during his administration,
even though his administration has done
a lot of shit to obstruct research on
marijuana,
things seemed to be changing.
Gay Marriage is now legal.
That's under his administration.
All those things.
The whistleblower stole that Shit.
See,
that's the shit that bugs me,
man.
And asked him about that.
No,
I don't think so.
I didn't.
I actually,
I had to.
I didn't.
I was listening to you.
Well,
I'll have to listen to it to see if he
did because that's super important
subject and the idea that someone who's
doing what they think is the right thing
for humanity by expressing they have a
huge issue with the legality of certain
actions that are,
that are commonplace.
It's fucked mean he seen,
he seen these things happen on a daily
basis and he thinks they're
unconstitutional and now he's hiding in
Russia,
man,
than how.
How crazy is that?
To me,
this is where you get into this problem
with presidents were and they kind of
remind you of like,
Oh fucking uncle,
uncle Jack.
What a cool guy.
Right?
He's a super sweet guys.
Really awesome.
He's so fun.
The kids really love him.
Everybody likes Uncle Jack,
but there's a car jacker.
You'll either that or he's like
molesting someone and you're supposed to
ignore the fact.
This is in families where I actually was
listening to this great documentary on
npr about the phenomena of why that kind
of shit is sexual abuse will happen in a
family and keep happening in a family
because to acknowledge it is to implode
the family to acknowledge it is to that
family is done and it happened.
This is when those.
I don't,
I don't even know.
I wasn't following the newest thing that
happened when that weird religious group
of people where there was sexual abuse
that happened.
I can't even remember their names.
So it's in relation to that,
but the doers,
right?
So the Duggar's,
so you in a family,
if you like,
admit that this is happening,
father,
mother,
uncle,
whoever is doing this thing,
you will transform the terrain of that
family permanently.
Right?
So in the same way with,
with the president,
you know,
it's,
we're almost being asked to do the same
exact thing,
which is like take the good.
He makes great hamburgers,
he gives the gate candy.
He's like really fun.
He's got a slip and slide,
but for God's sake,
never mentioned the time.
Two years ago when you were standing
behind the tool shed,
he slid his finger into your asshole
because if you do that,
it's fucking ruined our family in the
same way we would with like that with
Obama.
Man.
You're not supposed to you.
You just are like,
all right.
Just ignore the fact that right now
we're dealing with for profit prisons.
One of the greatest heroes of our time,
snowden was a real patriot,
is having to hide in fucking Russia
right now because we were supposed to
ignore the fact.
Even if Obama can't change it,
can he come out at a press conference
and say,
I support and endorse what snowden did.
Okay.
I
can't say that because then people will
be able to just hack into anything they
want and take information that the
government has distributed all around
the world and oh fuck up all sorts of
counter terrorism activities.
They're doing fuck up all sorts of
surveillance that they've got going on
with real questionable people.
That might be some fucking isis
character.
Yeah,
but I mean the whole you gotta you're
supposed to like kind of devil's
advocate buddy.
I know you are,
but and you literally are playing
devil's advocate,
but I don't mean to.
I don't mean to like get all
constitutional and everything,
but isn't the point of the president to
uphold the constitution and isn't,
but I don't think the constitution
existed when it was created with the
understanding of the Internet,
with the understanding of the
distribution of information,
with the understanding of covert
intelligence,
with the understanding of terrorism,
with the understanding of a lot of
things.
I think that was a real problem was that
first of all,
when,
when he did tell everybody that the NSA
spying on every fucking American on the
planet,
they lied.
Right?
That's bad.
That's a huge problem.
That's one problem.
And second of all,
there's no rational justification.
There was no significant number of
terrorism events.
They've.
They've stopped it while compromising
the privacy of everybody.
Then they started talking about how I
was just metadata and that wasn't true
either.
It's not just metadata.
People were going into the the emails of
their ex boyfriends and girlfriends and
reading their shit and downloading
pictures on their computers.
They're doing whatever the fuck they
wanted to do and they can do whatever
the fuck they want to do because they
have this autonomy.
They have this power working for the
NSA,
but what he was saying was like,
he was like,
I didn't even graduate from college,
and he goes and I have access to all
this stuff and I'm just a normal person.
I'm around a bunch of other people.
Yeah,
and I got this information.
I leak.
I got this information out to people.
What's the stop all these other people
from taking information.
What's to stop them from sharing it with
each other and passing it back and
forth?
Nothing.
Obviously if he was he able to leak as
much as he leaked.
What?
What safeguards are in place for
People's privacy?
Believe very little and whether or not
you're doing anything wrong,
whether or not you need to
worry about it,
that's not the argument.
The argument is it fundamentally changes
the relationship that you have with
another person.
The same way being a cop changes the
relationship.
When you're talking to someone that you
think is committing a crime,
all of a sudden you have power over that
person's information.
They don't have any over.
You could say,
sit down,
put your fucking hands over your head.
You'd be like,
no,
fuck you.
You sit down stupid fucking tumble and
your role with your stupid uniform on.
Don't put a point a gun at me.
I need to sit down because you're
pointing a gun at me.
You're an asshole or you need to put
your hands behind your back.
I'm going to handcuff you because I
don't trust you pointing a gun at me.
Pay Your bills,
dude.
I pay your bills and you're pointing a
gun at me or my daughter.
Right,
but no one is going to accept that.
No one's going to accept that you're not
gonna.
Accept that because a cop thinks he's a
cop and it's similar in a lot of ways.
It's similar.
The idea that someone has access to
Duncan trussell's email,
but you don't have access to.
There's no.
You don't even know they're there
checking in on you.
They have power over you and observing
you,
making sure you don't fuck up.
Guess what?
Just like how,
when you're talking about those,
uh,
those experiments that they do on
subatomic particles and waves and other
quantum shit with the observer changes
the effect.
Guess what?
When you fucking follow someone around
and observed the shit out of 'em,
uh,
changes them and changes them similar to
that stupid double blind double slit
experiment.
It's a wave and it's a particle.
You're innocent,
but you're also a criminal for diff.
Constantly following you trying to look
yet changes.
You fucking changes the way you feel if
someone's hounding you and fucking with
you.
It changes you.
Yeah,
man,
it's.
Yeah,
that didn't,
you know,
that's the thing.
It's like,
it's such a confused.
It's such a confusing thing to hear.
I mean,
I hear such an affable,
cool guy,
done some really great things and to
know that this other shit is going on.
It's just kinda sad man.
It'd be so beautiful if,
uh,
you know,
he,
he had actually shut down Guantanamo,
like the,
the,
uh,
staff coming back about either treating
those poor bastards like raw,
you know,
they're just like force feeding them
even though they want to die so they're
not even letting them die.
They're keeping them alive like
something from the hellraiser dimension,
just shoving tubes into their throat and
putting protein gel into their bellies.
And a lot of these guys,
I'm sure some of them are not great
people,
but I think a lot of them are probably,
they haven't even been given a trial.
You know,
there's a lot of them that got
interested in alternative ways to govern
and live lives and alternative
philosophies and religions and our
alternative ideologies and maybe even
militant ideologies that were curious.
They were curious about.
It doesn't mean that they've committed
any crimes.
Doesn't mean that they've.
I mean they might be,
but they might not be.
But the idea that all you have to do is
just be interested in these things and
they can lock you out a lock you up.
That's there's a thought crime aspect to
that.
That's really scary.
We got to hold.
The thing is,
God,
this sounds so cliche,
but you gotta hold your leaders
accountable.
You must hold leaders accountable and we
haven't doing it.
It
doesn't happen and because it doesn't
happen,
they keep taking more liberties and the
problem is we don't know how to hold our
leaders accountable because they're in
charge of everything.
So that's the predicament outside of
holding them accountable by voting or
hold the,
you know,
that's one way to do it,
but it's a really confusing,
you know,
again,
and again,
you hear the term war criminal thrown in
the direction of the Bush administration
and you know,
I don't know if it's true or not,
but I know there's never going to be a
trial.
I know that there's never going to be
any,
anything,
even close to a real investigation into
why we went to war there and what we did
while we were there and all that shit
just kind of gets swept down the river
of history and you're invited to ignore
it and look in the direction of the
progressive things that are happening
and they're great,
but then because great things are
happening does not mean that you ignore
all the other dark shit that's happening
and it doesn't mean that you're being a
conspiracy theorist or negative or
pessimistic because you won't let go of
the fact that the last few presidents
who've maybe done some shit that is,
seems to go directly against the rules
that were written down and whatever this
current game of being an American is.
And everybody's got to be held to those
rules.
If everyone's not held to those rules,
then we're all supposed to either wander
around in a state of denial and pretend
that everything's cool and it isn't.
Or we have to like,
I don't know.
What
did you hear about this?
Uh,
there's a great article that I tweeted
yesterday,
Isis and the lonely young American,
it's about this girl who's a 23 year old
Sunday school teacher and a babysitter
and she was a,
she converted to Islam.
She was lonely.
She was living with her grandparents.
She converted to Islam and it goes over
this long slow sort of story where it's
just like you,
you understand like who she is and how
she got sucked in and she fucking joins
isis.
Isis like offers her like some,
some feeling of belonging and she,
she goes through this process to join
isis.
I don't want to tell you any more of it.
I just want people to read it because
it's really fascinating and it's,
it's.
It also highlights an aspect of adhering
to ideologies that a lot of people don't
want to admit is that people are
extremely vulnerable because we don't
want to be alone.
And a lot of times when you see someone
who is absolutely committed to
something,
whether.
I mean,
how many times did people like seeing
that Bob Ross guy committing to painting
and they wanted to become a painter
because it's attractive when you see
someone who's into something you want to
Julia Child Cook or Anthony Bourdain
Cook,
you want to cook like God damn,
I don't want to cook too.
How's exciting?
Well,
when you see someone who's like really
into being a Muslim or really into being
a Buddhist or really into being a lot of
things,
you get sucked into it.
The archetype of like the Yogi,
like the people that are like that fake
bullshit sot nom you know,
no mas De,
you know those guys.
It was like an archetype that they sort
of follow into and they fall into it
because when you see it,
it looks like super attractive.
Like,
Oh wow,
that is like really spiritual.
I want to be like him.
Well,
there's people that are like that.
They're alone and they're sad and
they're vulnerable and being a Muslim
looks like a good idea to them.
Or being a Mormon looks like a good idea
to them being in in some sort of a group
that accepts you and pulls you in the
zero.
They're giving you interaction and
that's this.
This story is really fascinating because
it's something that I've always felt
compelled by because I felt minorly
compelled by all sorts of different
religions in my life will like I will
watch like even speeches are radical
Islamic speeches when these guys are
talking in front of these people,
in other parts of the world that speak
English,
but they're giant populations of them,
but there's something attractive even
though he's saying nobody shit about.
It says in the Koran,
you're supposed to stone adulterers and
it says in the Koran,
but they're good going over like,
how could you?
How could you possibly know better than
God?
This is the.
Is this not the greatest answer to this
problem that God has provided and
everyone will clap.
He goes,
thank you.
Then exactly like this is Islam,
and he was going on and that was like
the confidence that this guy has and
what he's saying becomes attractive even
to me.
Even to me,
okay,
I'm nowhere near joining Islam.
I'm nowhere near joining Isis.
I'm nowhere near becoming a mormon.
I'm becoming a scientologist,
but you know what I'm saying?
Man,
I'm watching this,
but I feel the draw.
Everyone feels a little bit because the
guy is,
he's compelling and and a lot of them
are religious people.
People that believe in wholeheartedly in
everything that they're saying and they
have charisma and they have passion
behind it.
Like I don't have those things.
I want to be like him because I feel
like he's giving off positive,
strong energy and if he's right,
if he's right about God and God really
is on the side of the righteous and he
will lead us towards God damn.
Guys seem super convinced.
I'm not convinced of anything like that,
but you get drawn into it.
I think one thing that you're
overlooking is the idea that I was at
sheldrake.
He talks about,
I think he used the term ease is the
term Murrano how like certain belief
systems create Ronald's and the time
space continuum or like they.
It kind of like like you know,
like in Conan when he's walking around
in the wheel,
the wheel and it he like he did like
from walking around so many times.
There's actually like a trench that he
takes out.
His groove comes to,
exist in the universe and those grooves
are the major world religions and so you
know right now,
not only are people shitting and float
tanks,
but right now at this very moment,
people and mosques in great numbers all
across the planet or intoning these very
sacred words that come from a mystical
book and they're singing them and that
creates a resonance that you can tune
into at anytime that you want to.
And that's the poll that I believe
you're feeling.
It's more than just I want to fit in or
I want to be a disciplined person.
It's like you start by dipping your toe
in this river of subjective universe,
which is whatever religion it is that
you're exploring and then you stick in
your foot and then you stick in your
other foot and the next thing you know
that motherfucker will suck you in and
we'll pull you into the into that
particular dance that a group of people
are doing and it's a very beautiful
dance to beautiful thing to watch.
We've talked about this a million times
before,
but when you're watching that and
credible drift of pilgrims is they're
moving around that.
What's the name of the cop that.
What's it called?
The Kaaba Makkah,
but it's called.
I don't know what it's called,
but I know we're talking about and it's
got a media right in it and his
beautiful surging ocean of people
dressed in white or like touching the
stone and it's incredible to watch and
it's really does help me to write in it.
Right?
I think it's immediate.
It's a black state.
I think it's a media.
It's a blackstone hold us up and it's
rundown from other fingers touching them
and if you think all those people in
that swirl of humanity or isis level,
fundamentalist lunatic assholes,
you're just tricking yourself because
you want the universe to be black and
white and it's not.
A lot of those people are really very
advanced beings who have just been drawn
into the particular way that the
universe expresses itself.
This is not to be trusted because it's
one of those World News daily report.
Dr.
Trusted.
What did they say?
It is Saudi Arabia.
Blackstone of Mecca.
Blackstone of Mecca revealed to be a
media.
Right.
It's a real problem with that.
Websites were printed though.
I mean,
I don't know what it is.
It's.
It's price.
Something weird though.
Media,
right.
Worship of the blocks down.
There's more than one website that says
that.
I'm got to go to wikipedia and look up.
Blacks done for some reason.
Wikipedia Islam's media at the circle.
At the Kaaba.
The Kaaba.
Yeah,
that's what it's called.
I'm googling it right in front of her.
Page two.
It says worship.
It's not what worship are Muslims,
but it is a media right inside that
thing though the Capa stone,
but it is.
Right.
So even if it's not worshiped by
Muslims,
it's at the center of their worship
spot.
I think that's probably significant.
Yeah,
that's pretty crazy.
But you know,
and the other black stone,
do you ever play as it is that it right.
There isn't the only image of blackstone
or hygiene.
Oral as swabbed is the eastern corner
stone of the Kaaba that the agent still
building,
located in the center of the Grand
Mosque in Mecca.
It is revered by Muslims is an Islamic
relic,
which according to Muslim tradition
dates back to the time of Adam and eve.
Dude,
go to the Google image search and you
can see the actual thing.
It looks like a vagina.
It's like the vagina of the universe.
Could imagine if that was like that.
Literally is the vagina of the universe
more like
a belly button.
Oh yeah.
It does have a kind of very vaginal wow.
The region
there and touching the vagina of the
universe.
Well,
I mean if that was a media right.
Okay,
and that means it came crashing down to
earth from the Schuylkill,
smoothly touching it.
I don't know where you've been buying
your walnuts.
I can go to a new place.
Looks like a dragon egg.
It looks like a vagina.
Goddamn man.
It's a dragon egg.
It's a vagina.
So if you think about it,
birth life came out of impact.
If it wasn't for the impact of comments,
we wouldn't have water apparently.
Is that true?
I believe that water came from comments.
I've heard that.
I don't know if they know that for sure,
but we do know for sure that if it
wasn't for the meteor impact that killed
the dinosaurs,
we'd be fucked.
We would not have made it.
Okay.
We've got neat and everywhere you look,
giant fucking dinosaurs have a loss of
raptors t rexes.
You never figured out the airplane.
If there was terra data,
you are taking too much time.
You fly around a jackie would eat you.
You'd be like,
fuck,
we can't fly yet.
We gotta kill all the carryback dose and
that you'd never get to them because you
can't fly.
So how are you going to get to them?
You'd have to get to the point where you
invented the the jet,
like a fighter jet where there was no
Tara Dac dolls.
That was the only way,
and then you have to fly over to where
the fuck they are.
Make sure you have a big tank of gas and
Jack All.
Make sure you kill all of them.
Then you can spread air travel.
Imagine if you had to try and sell
tickets for American Airlines and you
might get taken out by Tara dactyl the
fuck out of here.
No one's going to fly anywhere.
Most people wouldn't even fly on an
airline that has a last name.
Asia,
right?
At this point,
people are terrified about things drop
into the ocean.
If there was tared axles in the event of
a pterodactyl attack,
do not panic.
The key is to look like an egg.
They can't see very well.
The only they don't move.
They use egg edge detection in the very
unlikely event of a pterodactyl attack.
It's like,
well,
I feel.
I feel like that when I go swimming in
the ocean.
It's like,
you know,
sharks are the terra data.
How's that see there?
These ancient to mouth that are just
monsters grow.
Yeah.
That one in North Carolina,
like jaws is happening in North
Carolina.
Well,
how about two people got their arms cut
off inside of the day.
She's two people an hour apart from each
other.
Cut Their fucking arms bitten off.
First of all.
That second dude,
did he know about the first two because
that changes everything for a second.
Dude knew about the first dude in new.
They didn't catch the shark yet.
He's probably like,
well fuck man is full now.
Swimming in Hawaii when there's shark
attacks,
you know,
on Maui and we were there.
So many d I e deed.
Sure the kids are listening.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
We had to tell.
We haven't talked about that.
That did happen when I was there.
Dude happens all the time.
Yeah,
sure happens.
Yeah.
They like to keep that shit on the DL.
You know,
they'll talk about on the news out
there,
but the people on the island,
they're not scared.
You know?
I mean,
they just,
that's just life.
That's,
that's the,
the life that they live,
they don't want to get eaten by sharks,
but when I was there one time I was
there and someone and another
time I was there and there was a news
report.
Totally different time where this dude
got jacked.
He was fucked up.
He was in the hospital,
his leg was fucking eating apart and he
was just talking about what it felt like
and I was friend rescued him and then
the whole,
this is a regular occurrence.
I'm talking about two separate trips to
Hawaii to fucking shark attacks.
Both took place while I was there.
I was a little buzzed and almost fell
down a volcano inside.
Well not inside,
but like on the far side of it,
like because there's a fucking damn this
beautiful observation place where you
could look at a volcano and yeah man,
I.
There was a bar and I vote who I like
had a couple of Margarita is.
And then we were standing out there and
like I,
I kinda stumbled for a second and
realize I could've just gone sliding
down volcanic rock.
It wouldn't have been into lava.
Which will be a glorious way to die.
No,
you would have broken your legs and
starve to death and you'd be on like
18th youtube videos,
especially if you have a Gopro gopro
video of the dude who was on the
motorcycle got hit by a truck.
Now you haven't seen it.
You saw it.
Does he die?
Brian showed it to me the other night.
Um,
no.
He might as well be dead though.
He's just fucked beyond repair.
This is going fast and he hit on
collides with the truck.
God dammit.
Dude,
that sucks.
Woo.
It's crazy to watch.
Do you want to watch it?
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's add this to the beaker.
Goddammit.
This the tough.
Are you fucking kidding me dude?
I mean,
this is a fucking madness.
Uploaded the video he must have.
So he's okay.
I don't know.
I mean someone else picks up the Gopro
and starts filming him.
He's good enough to upload videos.
No,
no,
no.
Someone else picks up the Gopro,
but like,
stop.
I can't watch this anymore.
You can't play more than two times.
Well,
I hope he's doing okay now.
He's much better.
He might have.
He has nationwide need home insurance.
Geico.
Which ones?
Cars.
I'm a saying in my hands are sweating
from watching that.
Like feel.
Feel my hand right now.
Feel Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
I'm soaked.
Hyperhidrosis.
What does that sweaty lets me,
dude.
I'm hyperhidrosis.
Hyperhidrosis.
The Myth of height.
Yeah.
I get nervous anytime I get nervous.
My hands sweat.
Like crazy guy.
Mind to my body just thinks like you
better run.
Run like no,
we're just about to take a test.
No fucking run.
Dude.
Fucking run.
No,
no,
no.
We're just watching a youtube video.
No,
no.
The fucking truck is coming.
Fucking run.
I see the bike going towards the truck
and my hands start sweating like they
have to just run away somehow.
I don't know what's going on with your
body.
Like heating up.
Like it thinks it's a.
it's preparing to burst.
I don't know.
It's a great question because it doesn't
seem like it's going to help like sweaty
palms.
It's like worse.
If you want to grab onto something,
it's going to be harder to do it.
It seems weird.
I don't worst.
It's not good for anything.
Yeah.
Your.
Your grip gets
slippery for a pool.
It's like it was always a plague of
mine.
I used to actually spray anti perspirant
I'm a hands.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
and then I found this stuff called.
It's called like hands dry or dry hands
or something like that.
It's essentially like antiperspirant for
people that have a problem with the
doing something,
need to have dry hands.
Now it's squirted on my hands and rub
it,
rub it all over my hands and then it
would allow me to play pool better where
I could concentrate on just playing.
I didn't have to worry about my hands
wiping them down every five minutes like
I used to drink.
I used to bring a wet towel with me that
would wipe my hands with a wet towel and
then I would drive them off with a dry
towel and I had to do that over and over
and over again.
My hands are sweating for no reason,
no reason.
It was a stupid game,
knocking the ball into another ball and
I'm like life and death.
Life and death.
My body temperature is changing.
I'm sweating,
sweating over a fucking game.
Wasn't even for a lot of money,
you know,
playing a tournament or playing with a
buddy and my hands are sweating like an
asshole.
Yes.
Sweats.
Fucking weird,
isn't it?
What a strange thing that your body just
squirts out.
Saltwater whenever it gets too hot,
freaks out.
Well,
I've been on a hot yoga tear last two
and a half months.
I got to tell you,
first of all,
there's two things that have been doing
the last two and a half months really
regularly.
And I know one of them is not feasible
for a lot of people,
so don't complain.
And that's cryotherapy.
I know that Shit's expensive,
like 60 bucks every time you do it.
I'm fucking addicted dude.
I do it almost everyday.
Where do you do it?
I do it down here in woodland hills.
They have a place on Ventura Boulevard,
cryo healthcare.
There's another place in la,
but there's a lot of people that do it.
They just,
um,
it's not as effective,
but it's pretty fucking effective.
Just an ice bath.
Just fill up a tank filled with water or
a tub rather filled with water and a lot
of fucking ice and just climb on it and
it's a box,
but there's something that happens when
you ice yourself down like that.
The decrease of inflammation makes you
feel fucking fantastic and it allows
your body to heal more effectively.
Like dude,
extreme cold is incredible for
inflammation,
so I've done it every day except the
weekends.
I didn't do it the weekend he did
apparently to do today,
right before the show.
I do it.
I do it,
try to do it five days a week these days
and I'm doing it five days a week and I
fucking feel fantastic.
Fantastic.
I've heard that all my like little aches
and pains,
they're all like diminishing
significantly.
Everything seems to be like loosening up
and relaxing,
like what's the mechanics of that?
Like what?
Explain it.
But the other thing I'm doing is hot
yoga and the hot yoga in combination
with that is very interesting because
I've been doing the hot yoga at least
two days a week and then I'll do like
some other stretches,
like a third day a week with my other
workouts that I do.
But I'm forcing myself to do two days a
week of hot yoga.
It's fucking hard,
dude.
It's hard to do like surprisingly hard.
And the.
When the class is almost over,
I'm fucking exhausted.
I mean like really exhausted and so hot
that I want to quit.
I want to quit.
Like the last 10 minutes is don't be a
bitch.
That's the last 10 minutes.
All the exercises are fairly easy and
it's just don't leave yet.
Don't leave yet.
Hang in there.
And your body's like,
dude is too fucking hot near.
You've got to just deal with it.
Just deal with it and get through.
And there's this.
I don't know if you've ever seen the
podcasts I've done with Dr Rhonda
Patrick.
Nope.
I can't wait to talk to her about this,
but she's just brilliant,
brilliant lady,
and she wrote a paper about sauna and
one of the things about Saunas is that
they've experienced this radical
decrease in mortality rates amongst
people who take sauna and she was like,
it's a 40 percent decrease across the
board.
Everything with like cancer,
heart attacks,
all these different things.
There's an effect that's happening.
You mean like a steam hyper heat?
The Body Saunas?
Yeah.
You go into a sauna,
hot sauna.
There's something that happens when you
extreme,
when you extremely heat up the body
where the body has to respond to the
heat and then it develops this reaction
to these extreme temperatures for short
durations.
Now I don't know how much time you're
supposed to sit in a sauna,
but the time that you sit in a sauna,
whatever happens to your body,
once you get out and your body cools
itself down and there is a compensatory
mechanism that helps your body in some
crazy way that they're still trying to
understand now,
and the same can be said for Cryo
therapy and cryotherapy.
I think it's called sidechains,
like when you get below 150 degrees,
your body produces these anti
inflammatory responses.
There's Pub Med studies on it.
There's a bunch of different studies
explained to her.
I don't understand.
You don't because you're only in there
for three minutes.
Seems like a long time.
Seems like a long time while you're in
there too,
but it's enough that you can get out of
it.
Like when it gets more than three
minutes,
it gets real tricky and you don't have
to.
You don't touch anything like your hands
are in gloves,
surgical mask on your face.
You have earmuffs and the extremities
are covered.
Your extremities are covered with gloves
and your toes are covered with socks.
And then you wear crocs.
So you're standing in rubber crocs,
so your feet don't touch the out of your
cock.
Your cock is in your underwear.
Believe it or not,
the congress doesn't get that cold.
I mean,
I deal with it.
I deal with my cock,
my legs get cold,
my,
um,
my nipples get fucking cold.
Sometimes I wind up doing this.
I want to cover my nipples,
but for the most part what's happening
is your body is freaking the fuck out
because it's freezing cold and then
because the fact that it's not freezing
cold anymore,
it releases this burst of these
sidechains and this,
this feeling of just warmth and power
through your body where everything just
feels like things are knocked loose.
It's almost like a river runs through a
clogged up stream and knocks out all the
trees and I want to do it man.
Oh please.
I don't want to take it.
I'll take you tomorrow.
Want to go tomorrow?
I can't do it tomorrow.
When can you do it?
I got to look at my youtube.
Well,
we'll talk about it often off screen,
but you're going to do the comedy store
on Friday.
Let's do it before the comments died.
Done.
That's great.
Well,
there's one on La Sienna gotta.
Do a workout before that too.
Is that I will have like,
well sometimes I'll actually like to do
it after a freeze.
They like to freeze first and then work
out later,
but apparently
you can't do that with the ice bath.
So they were describing this the other
day.
Don't listen to me,
but this was something that they were
talking about.
Uh,
Ryan,
the guy who runs the woodland hills
location was telling me that if you was
telling somebody else I was
eavesdropping that if you do an ice
bath,
you're done for the day.
You don't work out today because you're
sitting in that thing for like 20
minutes and it's freezing cold and you
know,
you know,
you're apparently you could fuck
yourself up if you work out hard after
that.
Funny Man.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to cut you off.
You're so fucking cool.
I just realized that I realized like I'm
sitting talking to a guy and an
astronaut suit about going on Friday.
Freeze my body.
Ice Chamber Bucks.
Well listen man,
if you can do it,
you should do it.
It sounds awesome.
I would want to say,
and even like be the guy that tells
people while you're wearing a nasa suit
that you need to get a trier agentic
chamber for 270 degrees below zero for
three minutes.
Yeah,
you should do that.
I'm doing it.
I want to do it.
We can do these things.
Yeah.
You have an isolation tank in your
house.
You can do these things.
You have a fucking Mercedes now.
You can get these.
These things are happen.
So weird.
The world is weird.
So you're selling out all over the
country.
Ideas broke all the records in Boston
this weekend.
Oh good.
That makes a sold out in advance.
Before I even got there.
The place was packed.
What?
Uh,
what?
Relapse.
Boston.
Great Room.
You've done it.
I haven't done it.
It's very,
it's very good.
I haven't done.
My Boston is a reemerging comedy scene.
We're done with three minutes left.
Can I announce the show?
I have to.
Cool shows coming up.
I'm going to be at the Montreal comedy
festival,
uh,
doing a long,
doing a sat in a podcast.
And then what's really cool?
He just found out about this,
but I,
it'll be on my website soon.
Big Tour of Australia coming up in
November with Johnny Pemberton.
I'm going to be in Australia.
So anybody out there,
uh,
please come see me.
And Johnny and Australia.
Oh,
Duncan trussell.com.
Yes.
He R U S S E l l don't get it twisted.
Duncan trussell family hour.
Subscribe on itunes.
Listen away.
It's fucking awesome.
You're the best buddy.
I love you guys.
I love you too.
Joe v six six six to you.
What an honor to be on the show.
Peace and love.
You.
Dirty bitches will see soon.
Much love.
Big Kiss.